Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is, therestishistory.com. There's a hostage situation in the Olympic Village. You're sports, you're way over your head. People can't stop talking about September 5. It's a madhouse down here. It's one of the best movies of the year.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告内容、系列节目的抢先体验，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。再次重申，网址是 therestishistory.com。奥运村里发生了人质劫持事件。你们是体育记者，这完全超出了你们的职能范围。人们都在议论 9 月 5 日。这里简直疯了。这是今年最好的电影之一。
What's happening? Oh, God. September 5 in select theaters December 13. With TD Direct Investing, you can get live support. So whether you need help buying a partial share from your favorite tech company, opening a TFSA, or learning about investing tools, we're here to help. But keeping your cat off your keyboard, that's up to you. Reach out to TD Direct Investing today
发生什么了？哦，天哪。电影《9 月 5 日》将于 12 月 13 日在部分影院上映。通过道明自管投资（TD Direct Investing），您可以获得实时支持。因此，无论您是需要帮助购买您喜爱的科技公司的碎股、开立免税储蓄账户（TFSA），还是了解投资工具，我们都在这里为您提供帮助。但至于不让您的猫踩到键盘，那就得靠您自己了。今天就联系道明自管投资，
and make your investing steps count. Plus enjoy 1% cash back. Conditions apply, offer ends January 31st, 2025. Visit td.com slash DI offer to be great. I believed Warsaw would be great. I and my colleagues drew up plans for a great Warsaw of the future. And Warsaw is great. It happened sooner than we expected, not in 50 years, not in 100, but today. I see a great Warsaw. And as I speak to you now, through the windows I see, enveloped by clouds of smoke, reddened by flames, a wonderful, indestructible, great, fighting Warsaw in all its glory.
让您的每一步投资都算数。此外，还可享受 1% 的现金返还。条款适用，优惠截至 2025 年 1 月 31 日。访问 td.com 斜杠 DI offer 体验精彩。我曾坚信华沙会迎来伟大。我和我的同事们为未来的伟大华沙绘制了蓝图。华沙确实伟大。它比我们预期的更快到来，不是 50 年后，也不是 100 年后，而是今天。我看到了一个伟大的华沙。此时此刻，当我向你们说话时，透过窗户我看到，在滚滚浓烟和被烈火映红的火光包围中，一个奇妙的、不可摧毁的、伟大的、正在战斗的华沙正处于其全部的光辉之中。
And even though ruins lie where fine orphanages should stand, even though there are barricades where we wanted parks, even though our libraries are engulfed in flames, even though our hospitals are burning. They're not in 50 years, not in 100 years, but now today Warsaw, defending the honor of Poland, has reached the peak of its greatness and its glory." That was the mayor of Warsaw, Stefan Staszinski, who was broadcasting to the people of the Polish capital on the 23rd of September 1939. It is one of the most famous speeches in Polish history and even in translation it is, I mean, unbelievably moving and powerful. And all the more so Dominic, because of course
尽管本该矗立着优秀孤儿院的地方如今只剩下废墟，尽管我们想要公园的地方现在布满了路障，尽管我们的图书馆正被大火吞噬，尽管我们的医院正在燃烧。不是 50 年后，不是 100 年后，而是现在，今天，华沙，为了捍卫波兰的荣耀，已经达到了其伟大与荣耀的顶峰。”这是华沙市长斯特凡·斯塔任斯基（Stefan Staszinski）于 1939 年 9 月 23 日向波兰首都人民发表的广播讲话。这是波兰历史上最著名的演讲之一，即使翻译成其他语言，我的意思是，它也具有令人难以置信的感动力和力量。多米尼克，尤其考虑到这一点，因为当然
you can tell what the context for this is by his description. Warsaw is under attack. It's being pounded by German artillery. You've got the Luftwaffe, carpet bombing it from the skies, thousands of civilians dead, fires blazing out of control, much of the city in ruins and that great ode I guess to this sense of the invincible spirit of the Polish people but goodness I mean the invincible spirit of the Polish people has to go through a lot in this episode and has to go through a lot in the years that will follow the events of this episode because we are talking about the Nazi invasion
通过他的描述，你可以听出当时的背景是什么。华沙正遭受攻击。它正遭到德国火炮的猛烈轰炸。空军（Luftwaffe）在空中对其实施地毯式轰炸，数千名平民死亡，大火失控，大部分城市变成废墟，这首伟大的颂歌，我猜，是对波兰人民不可战胜的精神的一种赞颂，但天哪，我的意思是，波兰人民不可战胜的精神在这集里经历了很多苦难，在这一集事件之后的几年里也将经历极大的苦难，因为我们正在谈论的是纳粹的入侵
and conquest of Poland. Yes, it's an incredibly bleak story, Tom, and it is an amazing speech. Very moving to even to hear you reading it out, you have a bit of a kind of lump in your throat, the kind of idea of Warsaw reaching the apotheosis of its glory in circumstances of the most terrible horror. Four days after that speech, after Stasins he gave that speech, the city surrendered. He ended up being arrested by the Gestapo and he vanished. He was never seen again. It's not clear whether he was shot in Warsaw or whether he was taken to a concentration camp and murdered. If you go to Warsaw, there
和对波兰的征服。是的，这是一个极其凄凉的故事，汤姆，这是一场惊人的演讲。甚至连听你朗读出来都让人感到非常动容，你听上去有些哽咽，华沙在最为恐怖的环境中迎来了其荣耀的顶峰，这种想法……在那次演讲的四天后，在斯塔任斯基发表了那场演讲后，这座城市投降了。他最终被盖世太保逮捕，随后便销声匿迹了。他再也没有出现过。目前尚不清楚他是在华沙被枪决，还是被送往集中营并遭谋杀。如果你去华沙，
are loads of monuments to him, the streets named after him and things. And at the end of the 20th century, he was voted the Vast Soviet of the century. So his memory certainly in Poland definitely lives on. But I guess it would be wrong for us to pretend that this episode is going to be anything other than quite a dark story. Oh, I mean, unbelievably bleak. So we ended last time with the war breaking out, the first shots of the war being fired in Danzig after these false flag incidents on the border. So 4.45, Saturday the 1st of September, the German battleship the Schleswig-Holstein opening fire on the Polish munitions depot on
那里有大量关于他的纪念碑，有以他的名字命名的街道等等。在 20 世纪末，他被评选为“世纪华沙人”。因此，他的记忆在波兰显然长存。不过，如果我们假装这一集不会是一个相当黑暗的故事，那就大错特错了。哦，我的意思是，极其凄凉。所以我们在上一集结束时，战争爆发了，在边境发生这些假旗行动（false flag incidents）之后，战争的第一枪在但泽（Danzig）打响。那是 9 月 1 日，星期六，凌晨 4 点 45 分，德国战列舰“石勒苏益格-荷尔斯泰因号”（Schleswig-Holstein）向
the Westerplatte peninsula and the harbour. And at the same time, the German police in Danzig and the SS launched an attack on the Polish post office in the city, which they saw as long seen as a standing affront. Now those two moments, the attack on the Westerplatte depot and the attack on the post office are incredibly well known stories in Poland. If you go to what's now Gdansk, there are monuments, there are museums. I mean, it is a place incredibly rich in history, particularly Second World War history, and they've become part of patriotic legends. So let's start with those two stories and tell people what happened. So first of all, the Westerplatte. So this is this, it's basically a munitions depot on this sort of
威斯特盘德（Westerplatte）半岛及港口的波兰军火库开火。与此同时，但泽的德国警察和党卫军（SS）对该市的波兰邮政局发动了进攻，他们长期以来一直将此视为一种公然的挑衅。现在，这两个时刻——对威斯特盘德军火库的袭击和对邮政局的袭击，在波兰是广为人知的历史事件。如果你去现在的格但斯克（Gdansk），那里有纪念碑，有博物馆。我的意思是，这是一个历史底蕴极其丰富的地方，尤其是第二次世界大战的历史，它们已经成为了爱国传奇的一部分。让我们从这两个故事开始，向听众讲述发生了什么。首先是威斯特盘德。这是一个，基本上是一个位于这种狭长地带上的军火库。
neck of land. There were about 200 Polish soldiers there guarding the depot and they were completely cut off. So they're the first people to come under fire. And they refused to surrender. And over the next few days, the Germans made 13 separate attempts to storm the peninsula, including sending dive bombers to hit them. And these 200 guys held out for a week and that was a week longer than even their own officers had thought possible. And at the time it was a massive story in Poland. So every day on Polish radio, the news bulletins would have the phrase, the Vesta Plata fights
那里大约有 200 名波兰士兵守卫着军火库，他们完全被切断了退路。因此，他们是第一批遭到攻击的人。他们拒绝投降。在接下来的几天里，德国人对半岛发动了 13 次不同的突击，包括派遣俯冲轰炸机进行轰炸。这 200 名士兵坚持了一个星期，这比他们自己的军官认为可能的还要多坚持了一个星期。当时这在波兰是一个轰动全国的大新闻。因此，波兰广播电台每天的新闻简报中都会有一句话：“威斯特盘德仍在战斗”。
on. So it's kind of like Thermopylae, isn't it? A doomed heroic last stand. Yeah. And Polish historians use that exact parallel. They call it the Polish themopoli. And these guys finally surrendered on the 7th of September. So a week longer than they'd fought for a week longer than they should have done. Because they basically, they've run out of supplies and those men who'd been wounded were dying of gangrene.
这有点像温泉关（Thermopylae），不是吗？一场注定失败但英勇的最后抵抗。是的。波兰历史学家就用了这个确切的比喻。他们称之为“波兰的温泉关”。这些人最终在 9 月 7 日投降了——比他们原本应该坚持的时间多战斗了一个星期。因为基本上，他们的补给耗尽了，那些受伤的人也因坏疽而濒临死亡。
And this is pretty much the only time in this episode when the Germans behaved nobly, and they did behave very nobly. So when the Poles came out, the Germans couldn't believe their eyes. They thought there'd been 2000 of them and there were only 200. And the German commander who was a guy called Friedrich Georg Eberhardt was actually very gallant to the Polish commander who was called Henryk Sucasky. Sucasky gave him his sword and surrender, his saber and E Abelhard gave it him back and said, no, you keep it. And then lined up his men and as their poles came out, the Germans all saluted
这也是本集中德军表现得相当高尚的几乎唯一一次，而他们的确表现得非常高尚。当波兰人走出来时，德国人简直不敢相信自己的眼睛。他们以为那里有 2000 人，但实际上只有 200 人。德军指挥官名叫弗里德里希·格奥尔格·埃伯哈特（Friedrich Georg Eberhardt），他对波兰指挥官亨利克·苏查斯基（Henryk Sucharski）表现得非常骑士风度。苏查斯基在投降时交出了他的军刀，而埃伯哈特把它还了回去，并说：“不，你留着它。”接着，他让部下排成队列，当波兰人走出来时，德国人纷纷向他们敬礼，
them as they were kind of led off into captivity, and Abelhard said to his men, that's how you fight. That's how you defend your honor. Look at those poles and look at what they've done. Because the gallantry of it, the nobility of it, of that scene, I mean, it blazes all the brighter, doesn't it, for the near universal darkness that effectively is the rest of this invasion. Exactly, exactly, because there's such a contrast with what happened at the other totemic battle
当时他们正被押往战俘营，埃伯哈特对他的部下说：“这就是战斗的方式。这就是捍卫荣誉的方式。看看这些波兰人，看看他们所做的一切。”因为那种骑士风度，那种高尚，在整个入侵行动近乎普遍的黑暗背景下，显得愈发熠熠生辉，不是吗？确实如此，确实如此，因为这与在但泽发生的另一场标志性战役形成了鲜明的对比，
in Danzig, which is the post office. So the post office was being held by 56 people. They were mostly post men and their families, and they were armed with pistols and grenades. So they're not soldiers, they're not in uniform? No. And the SS hammered them with howitzers and grenades and whatnot and didn't get any joy. And as dusk was falling, the SS resorted to a very brutal tactic. They brought up a railway carriage filled with petrol and they used fire hoses from the fire engines to pump this petrol into the building.
那就是邮政局战役。当时邮政局里有 56 人在坚守。他们大多是邮政人员及其家属，武装只有手枪和手榴弹。所以他们不是士兵，他们没有穿军服？没有。党卫军用榴弹炮、手榴弹等武器猛烈轰击他们，但没有取得什么进展。随着夜幕降临，党卫军采取了一种非常残酷的战术。他们开来了一节装满汽油的铁轨车厢，并用消防车的消防水带将这些汽油泵入大楼内。
And then they set lights to the building with grenades. So the building went up like a, you know, like a candle and three poles were burned alive straight away and the rest kind of surrendered and rushed out of the building. The first guy that came out was the post office director and he was holding a white flag and the Germans shot him dead straight away. The next bloke, they pushed him back into the building so that he burned alive. And then they spared the others at first. But for precise to the point that you said that they are postmen and not soldiers. They were rounded up and they were told you were illegal competence. You weren't
然后他们用手榴弹点燃了建筑物。于是大楼像一支蜡烛一样腾地燃烧起来，三名波兰人当场被活活烧死，其余的人则纷纷投降并冲出大楼。第一个出来的是邮政局局长，他手里拿着一面白旗，德国人当场开枪把他打死了。下一个家伙，他们把他推回大楼里，结果他也活活烧死了。随后，他们起初饶了其他人。但针对你刚才所说的他们是邮政人员而不是士兵这一点。他们被集中起来，并被告知你们是“非法战斗人员”。你们不是
fighting legally. And so they are immediately court-martialed by the Wehrmacht. They were all shot by SS firing squads and buried in a mass grave. So a very, very dark story. Again, there's a big monument to the postman in Gdansk. And it's actually this whole story is a chapter of Gunter Grass's book, The Tin Drum, which is set in inzig-Gedansk as it became. So while all that's going on, German forces, as we said last time, 60 divisions, one and a half
合法参战的。因此，他们立即被德意志国防军（Wehrmacht）进行军事法庭审判。他们全部被党卫军行刑队枪决，并被埋葬在一个万人坑里。这是一个非常、非常黑暗的故事。同样，格但斯克也有一座纪念邮政局人员的大型纪念碑。事实上，整个故事是君特·格拉斯（Gunter Grass）的小说《铁皮鼓》（The Tin Drum）中的一个章节，该小说的背景就设定在但泽（后来的格但斯克）。因此，在这一切发生的同时，正如我们上次所说，德国军队，60个师，150
million men are spearheaded by tanks. They are pouring over the borders of Poland. And actually, the first person to break the news of this story was a journalist from of all places, The Daily Telegraph. So British newspaper and this was a great war correspondent, then very young, 27 years old called Claire Hollingworth. And she had only been working for The Telegraph for a couple of weeks. I mean, basically everybody who works at The Telegraph now is about 27, aren't they? I mean, isn't that the nature of The Daily Telegraph? But then she must have been basically the youngest person they employed by about 50 years. They had sent her, she'd gone off to Silesia, to Katowice,
万大军，以坦克为先锋。他们正涌入波兰边境。事实上，最先打破这一消息的人是一名记者，而且来自出人意料的地方——《每日电讯报》（The Daily Telegraph）。这是一份英国报纸，而这位伟大的战地记者当时非常年轻，年仅 27 岁，名叫克莱尔·霍林沃思（Claire Hollingworth）。她当时在《电讯报》工作才仅仅几周。我的意思是，基本上现在在《电讯报》工作的人也都 27 岁左右，对吧？我的意思是，《每日电讯报》不就是这种风格吗？但在当时，她可以说是他们雇用的最年轻的人，比其他人年轻了大约 50 岁。他们派她去西里西亚（Silesia）的卡托维兹（Katowice），
to cover the story of the tension in Poland. And she looked out of her hotel room and she heard all these planes going overhead and literally saw German tanks kind of driving down the street. And she rang the British embassy in Warsaw and said, I mean, it's on, the Germans are attacking. And the embassy said, well, we haven't heard anything about this. So, you know, you're making it up. And she literally held the phone out of the window. And again, it's a reminder, isn't it? Of how in so many ways, how distant this war is because now communications
去报道波兰紧张局势的新闻。她向酒店房间外望去，听到头顶上飞过各种飞机，并且亲眼看到德国坦克沿着街道开过来。她给英国驻华沙大使馆打电话说，我的意思是，战争开始了，德国人正在进攻。大使馆却说，嗯，我们没听说这事儿啊，所以，你在胡编乱造吧。她索性把电话举到窗外。这再次提醒了我们，不是吗？在很多方面，这场战争显得如此遥远，因为现在的通讯
are so instantaneous, the fact that you have to have a journalist on the frontier, holding a telephone out, exactly form the British embassy of what's happening. It just seems incomprehensible. It does. Yeah, absolutely. I mean, obviously, you know, far, far closer to the great war than it is to us. Right. I mean, even though we think of the second world war, probably because of the, the
如此瞬息万变，而你当时竟然必须让一名记者站在前线，把电话伸出窗外，来向英国大使馆汇报正在发生的事情。这简直令人匪夷所思。确实如此。是的，绝对如此。我的意思是，很显然，你知道的，这（二战）离第一次世界大战要远得多，而离我们……对的。我的意思是，尽管我们认为第二次世界大战，可能是因为
moving pictures, because color imagery. Yeah, exactly. We, we think of it as more immediate. Right from the start, it is clear the Poles are facing massive, massive challenges. As we heard last time, the British and the French had persuaded them not to mobilize early to avoid provoking the Germans. So they're not ready. A lot of their reservists haven't got to their barracks. Those who have have not been issued with guns. They're not in any condition really to face this incredibly well drilled war machine of
动态影像，因为彩色影像。是的，绝对如此。我们觉得它更加直观。从一开始，就很明显，波兰人正面临着巨大、巨大的挑战。正如我们上次听到的那样，英法两国曾说服他们不要过早动员，以免激怒德国人。所以他们根本没有准备好。他们的许多预备役人员甚至还没赶到军营。那些已经到达的人也没有发到枪支。他们根本不具备应对希特勒这台训练有素的战争机器的状态。
Hitler's. And even if they had been, this is going to be a very tough ask. So if you look at the map, Germany can attack Poland from three different sides, from the main body of the Reich in the West, from East Prussia, which is in the North. And they can also attack. It's often forgotten that Germany is not the only country that attacks Poland because they have their client state now Slovakia. Oh, and the Catholic priest. And the Catholic priest Monsignor Tiso said they attack from the south as well. And Slovakia is the only bit where there's any natural barrier, which is the Tartarus Mountains.
退一步说，即使他们做好了准备，这也是一项极其艰难的任务。如果你看一下地图，德国可以从三个不同的方向进攻波兰：从西部的帝国本土、从北部的东普鲁士（East Prussia）。他们还可以进攻。人们经常忘记，德国并不是唯一一个进攻波兰的国家，因为他们现在有了一个附属国——斯洛伐克。哦，还有那个天主教神父。那个天主教神父约瑟夫·蒂索（Monsignor Tiso）说他们也从南部发起进攻。斯洛伐克是唯一拥有天然屏障（即塔特拉山脉）的地方。
But in the west, there is no natural barrier at all. It is just flat farmland. And as it happens, it's been a very, very dry summer. The rivers have dried up. We'll maybe come to this a bit later. So there's no mud to clog up the... Nothing. The tanks can just... It's perfect. The tanks can just roll over the border. Now, as for the two armies, we said the Germans attacked one and a half million men. The Poles have about a million men, many of them infantry, and they have about another million reserves. But Poland is so much poorer than Germany that they are much less well trained and less well equipped. So there's a brilliant book called The Eagle Unbowed on Poland in the
但在西部，根本没有任何天然屏障。那里只有平坦的农田。碰巧的是，这是一个非常、非常干燥的夏天。河水都干涸了。我们或许稍后会谈到这一点。所以没有泥浆去阻挡……什么都没有。坦克可以直接……太完美了。坦克可以直接横扫边境。至于这两支军队，我们说过德国人投入了 150 万兵力进攻。波兰大约有 100 万兵力，其中许多是步兵，他们还有大约 100 万预备役部队。但波兰比德国穷得多，因此他们的训练和装备都要逊色得多。所以有一本绝佳的书，叫做《不屈之鹰：第二次世界大战中的波兰》（The Eagle Unbowed: Poland and the Second World War），作者是英籍波兰历史学家哈利克·科尚斯基（Halik Kochanski）。
Second World War by Halik Kowchanski, who's an Anglo-Polish historian. And she points out Poland's annual defence budget was 50 times smaller than Germany's. And in fact, it was only a tenth of the budget just for the Luftwaffe. So that tells you what a disadvantage they're fighting. The Germans have 15 times more armoured and mechanised units than the Poles do. If you think about the air war, which is very important, the Luftwaffe have 2000 fighters, the Poles have 300 and something. The Polish airmen, by the way, are considered some of the best in the world. Well, because they go on to fight in the Battle of Britain, don't they? With tremendous heroism in the Battle of Britain. But there aren't that many of them and they
她指出，波兰的年度国防预算比德国小 50 倍。事实上，它甚至只相当于德国空军（Luftwaffe）一家的预算的十分之一。这说明了他们在极其不利的条件下作战。德国人的装甲和机械化部队是波兰的 15 倍。如果你想想空军战争，这非常重要，德国空军有 2000 架战斗机，而波兰只有 300 架左右。顺便说一句，波兰飞行员被认为是世界上最优秀的飞行员之一。嗯，因为他们后来参加了不列颠之战（Battle of Britain），不是吗？在不列颠之战中表现出极大的英雄主义。但他们的人数没那么多，飞机也不多。
don't have many planes. Again, I mean, I know that I keep going on about this, but it seems bizarre that the country with the impregnable defences, i.e. Czechoslovakia, gives them up and Poland that has no defences at all fights. I suppose it's partly because Czechoslovakia has already been defeated though, the Poland fights, right? They've already seen what happens if you don't fight. So they feel they have no choice. Anyway, within hours, it is obvious that the polls, I mean, with hours, not days, hours, it is obvious that the polls, I mean, with hours, not days, hours, it is clear that the polls are in real trouble, because this is the first demonstration of the Germans' famous blitzkrieg, lightning war tactics. So in the Great War, in the First
再说一次，我知道我一直在唠叨这个，但拥有坚不可摧的防御（即捷克斯洛伐克）的国家却放弃了抵抗，而毫无防御能力的波兰却奋起抵抗，这实在是匪夷所思。我想这部分是因为捷克斯洛伐克当时已经被击败了，而波兰还在战斗，对吧？他们已经看到了如果不抵抗会发生什么。所以他们觉得自己别无选择。无论如何，不出数小时，情况就很明显了——波兰人，我是说，用小时而不是天来计算，几个小时内，就很明显了，波兰人，我是说，用小时而不是天，几个小时内，很显然，波兰人陷入了真正的麻烦，因为这是德国著名的“闪电战”（blitzkrieg）战术的首次展示。所以在第一次世界大战中，
World War, you had these gigantic armies advancing over a huge front that could be tens, hundreds of miles wide. The thing that the Germans do now is they concentrate their armies into these columns that move very quickly, that punch a hole through your line and then keep going causing complete chaos. And is this a strategy that's been formulated or is it one that evolves in the context of the war? I think a bit of both. So armies always have doctrines, so they will have a kind of idea of an ideal of what to
你拥有庞大的军队在一个巨大的正面（宽达几十甚至上百英里）上推进。而德国人现在所做的是，他们将军队集中成快速移动的纵队，在你的防线上撕开一个缺口，然后长驱直入，造成彻底的混乱。这是一种经过周密构思的战略，还是在战争背景下演变出来的产物？我认为两者兼而有之。军队总是会有军事条令，所以他们会对该做什么有一个大致的理想理念，他们有理论，但一旦付诸实践，你总是会根据实际情况进行调整，看看什么行之有效。因为这种速度和暴力的理念是非常法西斯主义的，对吧？我猜是的。非常法西斯主义，完全正确。当然，这也是技术变革的产物，也就是你现在拥有了第一次世界大战中所没有的机械化部队。但令人瞩目的，我的意思是，呃……因为很显然法国人并没有采用这种战术。不。
do, they have a theory, but then once you put it into practice, you'll always adjust, you'll see what works. Because the idea of speed and violence is very fascist, isn't it? I guess. It's very fascist, exactly. And of course, it's a product of technology of the technological change, the fact that you now have mechanized units in a way that you didn't in the first war. But it's striking, I mean, the, um, because obviously the French do not adopt this. No.
戴高乐对此非常热衷，但他在这方面没有任何话语权。然而，纳粹最高指挥部推行这种战术，大概是因为它符合他们对德国军队应有表现的认知。我想是的。我认为，他们可能较少受到传统束缚，因为当然，他们是最近才重新武装的。是的。他们是最近才重建军队的。我想空军也是如此，对吧？
The goal is very keen on it, but he doesn't have any leeway with that. But it presumably it's adopted by the Nazi high command because it conforms with their sense of how a German army should be performing. I think so. I think, um, they're less side-bound by convention maybe because of course they've re-armed more recently. Yeah. They've rebuilt their army more recently. I suppose that's also true of the air force, isn't it?
他们必须从零开始建立空军，尽管它因此而更加先进。正是如此，绝对如此。事实上，这也是他们的另一项伟大创新，与闪电战战术相辅相成。所以在第一天，德国人就投入了 900 架轰炸机和 500 架战斗机作战。他们的空军正如你所说，是一支崭新的空军，是世界上最现代化的空军之一。他们在西班牙通过“秃鹰军团”（Condor Legion）磨练了技能，
They've had to build it from scratch, though it's that much more advanced. Exactly, right. Exactly. And actually, this is their other great innovation that goes hand in hand with the Blitzkrieg tactics. So on the first day, the Germans throw 900 bombers and 500 fighters into action. Their air force, which is, as you say, is new, is one of the most modern in the world. They've honed their skills, as it were, in Spain, the Condor Legion,
并在第二天基本上就赢得了制空权。他们消灭了天空中的波兰空军，轰炸了他们的机场。他们主宰了蓝天。现在，关于轰炸的这一点，我认为非常重要，这也是与第一次世界大战一个非常明显的区别。因此我们在本系列中曾多次讨论过，20世纪30年代欧洲各地的评论员如何对轰炸痴迷不已。所以轰炸机总是能突破防线，如果未来发生战争，平民将为此付出代价，而这正是轰炸潜力的伟大展示，甚至比格尔尼卡（Guernica）更甚，后者
and they've pretty much won the battle for the skies by day two. Wiped the Polish Air Force in the skies, bombed their aerodromes. They command the heavens. Now, this thing about bombing, I think, is really important and is a very obvious difference with the First World War. So we've talked a few times in this series about how commentators everywhere in Europe in the 1930s were obsessed with bombing. So the bomber will always get through, civilians will pay the price if there's ever a future war and this is the great demonstration of bombing's potential, even more so actually than Guernica, which had
此前曾是最著名的教科书式案例。也就是在西班牙北部。所以在西班牙的格尔尼卡，在巴斯克地区，历史学家现在估计格尔尼卡大约有 300 名平民死亡。当时这些数字被极大地夸大了。但在波兰，这是完全不同的规模。这很有趣。这表明了我们的盲目性，我猜，我们对这些并不了解，这些并没有成为家喻户晓的名字，
previously been the most famous kind of object lesson. So that's in Spain and in Northern Spain. So Guernica in Spain, in the Basque country, probably historians now think probably about 300 people died at Guernica civilians. There was, these were greatly inflated figures at the time. But in Poland, it's on a completely different scale. It's interesting. It's a sign of our blinkeredness, I guess, that we don't know about this, that these aren't household names
就像格尔尼卡那样，因为那是东欧，所以人们有点把那段历史给忘了。嗯，我想是因为他们没有一个伟大的艺术家去画它。确实如此，当然。所以毕加索对它的画作成为了轰炸行动的某种标志，不是吗？确实是这样。因此，它在某种程度上代表了在战争期间所有遭受轰炸之苦的人。
in the way that Guernica is, because it's Eastern Europe, so people kind of forget about that. Well, they didn't have a great artist painting, I suppose. That's true, of course. So Picasso's image of it is the kind of icon of bombing campaigns, isn't it? It is, absolutely. So it kind of does stand in for everybody else who suffers from it over the course of the war.
确实如此。是的，你完全正确。但是，听这个播客的人中，可能没有人或极少数人听说过一个叫维伦（Wielun）的小镇，这是波兰中西部的一个农村小镇。这只是一个小镇，在 9 月 1 日进攻的第一个小时内就遭到了德国空军的轰炸。德国空军对其轰炸了九个小时。他们投下了 400 枚炸弹，总共 50,000 公斤的炸药。他们几乎把整个镇中心夷为平地。平民死亡人数——我的意思是，有不同的估计。他们甚至高达 1200 人左右，这大约是全镇总人口的十分之一。但问题是，这是一个没有任何
It does. Yeah, you're absolutely right. But so no one probably or very few people listening to this podcast would have heard of a town called Wielun, which is a rural town in west central Poland. So this was just a sort of small town hit by the Luftwaffe in the first hours of the attack on the 1st of September. The Luftwaffe bombed it for nine hours. They dropped 400 bombs, a total of 50,000 kilograms of explosives. They almost completely leveled the town centre. The civilian death toll, I mean there are different estimates there. They go as high as about 1200 people, so that's a tenth of the entire population. But the thing is, this was a town with no
军事目标的城镇。所以它是被蓄意瞄准以制造恐怖气氛的？恐怖。正是来自空中的恐怖才是真正的……第一次世界大战中几乎没有这样的事情。你会有这样的故事：德国飞机偏离航线去攻击难民纵队，蓄意向救护车开火，轰炸医院列车，他们会轰炸一辆火车，然后乘客们……火车会脱轨。幸存下来的乘客全都……你知道的，从空中俯瞰，他们可能看起来像是一群昆虫在风景中四处逃窜。然后飞机又会折返回来赶尽杀绝，在他们逃跑时用机枪扫射。这样的场景即使是对战争最有经验的观察员也感到骇然。因此，当时波兰军事特派团的负责人实际上是一个了不起的人物。
military targets in it at all. So it's deliberately targeted to create terror? Terror. And it's the terror from the air that is the real, there's very little like this in the first world war. And you have these stories, German planes that stray for refugee columns that fire deliberately on ambulances that bomb hospital trains, and they will bomb a train and then the passengers, the train will kind of come off the tracks. The passengers who survived were all, you know, like a sort of, from above, they probably look like, you know, kind of insects sort of flooding across the landscape. And then the planes will come back down for the
这个人叫阿德里安·卡顿·德·维尔特（Adrian Carton de Wiart），他一只眼睛失明，还少了一只胳膊。就像纳尔逊（Nelson）一样。就像纳尔逊。如果我告诉你，他在维基百科上的生平简介是以这样的话开头的：在第一次世界大战中，它说，他的面部、头部、腹部、脚踝、腿部、臀部和耳朵都中过枪，左眼失明，经历了两次飞机坠毁，从战俘营挖地道逃生，并在医生拒绝截肢时自己扯断了手指。
kill and machine gun them as they flee. Scenes like this appall even the most experienced observers of war. So the head of the military mission in Poland was actually, he was an amazing character. This guy, Adrian Carton de Wiart, who had one eye and he had one arm. Like Nelson. Like Nelson. And if I tell you, his Wikipedia entry begins with the words, in the First World War, it says, he was shot in the face, head, stomach, ankle, leg, hip and ear, was blinded in his left eye, survived two plane crashes, tunneled out of a prisoner of war camp and tore off his own fingers when a doctor declined to amputate them.
他曾这样评价第一次世界大战：“坦白说，我很享受那场战争。”所以他就是那个在观察这一切的人。所以他不是个懦夫？不，他不是懦夫。这就是有趣的地方。他说，他感到震惊。他说：“这不是我所理解的战争。”卡顿·德·维尔特说，随着第一次对平民的蓄意轰炸，我看到了
And he said of the First World War, frankly, I enjoyed the war. So he's the guy who's observing all this. So he's not a wuss? No, he's not a wuss. And this is the interesting thing. He says, he is appalled. He says, this is not war as I understand it. Carton de Ville said, with the first deliberate bombing of civilians, I saw
战争的面目发生了改变，浪漫主义荡然无存，荣耀被剥夺，不再是士兵奔赴战场，而是妇女和儿童被埋葬在废墟之下。我能否在这个时候插一句，我知道你曾写下此事并把它写进了笔记里，但后来因为担心时间不够又删掉了，但我认为还是应该提一下，因为这可能是大多数听这一集的听众对纳粹入侵波兰早期阶段唯一有所耳闻的事情，也就是一种模糊的、不成熟的印象，即战争的浪漫与荣耀是由波兰骑兵手持长矛冲锋坦克来维护的。是的。而这不是真的。他们并没有这样做。不过，确实发生过骑兵交战。所以在纳粹入侵的头几个小时里，有一场著名的骑兵交战，
the very face of war change, bereft of romance, its glory shorn, no longer the soldier setting forth into battle, but the women and children buried underneath it. Could I just ask at this point, I know that you wrote about this and put it in your notes and then removed it because you were worried about time, but I think it should mention it because it's probably the one thing that most people listening to this episode will know about the early days of the Nazi invasion of Poland, which is a vague, inchoate sense that the romance of glory of war is upheld by Polish lancers charging Panzers. Yeah. And this is not true. They did not do this. However, there were cavalry engagements. So there's a famous cavalry engagement in the first hours of
一群德国士兵进入了一片森林中的空地，波兰骑兵部队看到了他们，攻击了他们，并将他们赶出了森林。尽管他们随后遭到装甲车辆的攻击和机枪扫射，损失了大约三分之一的人员和马匹，但其余的人都成功突围了。他们阻滞了德军的推进几个小时，并使波兰军队得以撤退。所以这非常具有英雄主义色彩。然后德国人邀请国际记者来参观这场小规模冲突、这场战役的现场，那里有肠子被掏出来的马匹和战死的波兰骑兵、波兰骑兵。而其中一位为意大利报纸撰稿的记者，
the Nazi invasion, where a group of German soldiers have moved into a forest clearing in a forest. soldiers have moved into a forest clearing in a forest, that Polish cavalry units see them, attack them, clear them out of the forest. And although they then get attacked by armored vehicles and machine gunned, and they lose about a third of their men and horses, the rest get away. They have held up the German advance for a few hours and enable Polish forces to drop back. So very kind of heroic. And then the Germans invite international journalists to come and look at the scene of this skirmish, this battle, and there were kind of horses with their guts ripped out
他把这篇报道写成“骑兵冲锋坦克”。我猜这之所以产生共鸣，是因为波兰人于 1683 年抵达维也纳解围的著名历史故事。维也纳之翼骑兵。是的，所有这些。因此，对一些波兰人和当然还有外国同情者来说，这成为了一个已经消逝的骑士时代的象征。而对纳粹来说，这成了波兰落后的象征。因此，连君特·格拉斯——你提到了《铁皮鼓》——我的意思是，
and dead cavalrymen, Polish cavalrymen. And one of these journalists who's writing for an Italian paper, he writes it up as cavalry charging tanks. And I guess it resonates because of the famous story of the Poles arriving at the siege of Vienna in 1683. The winter stars. Yeah, all of that. And so for, I mean, I suppose for some Poles and certainly for foreign sympathizers, it becomes emblematic of an age of chivalry. It has been destroyed. Whereas for the Nazis, it serves as an emblem of Polish backwardness. So even Gunter Grass, you mentioned the tin drum. I mean,
他把波兰骑兵描述为某种唐吉诃德（Don Quixote），进而把整个波兰国家也这样描述。所以这是一种有趣的矛盾心理，不是吗？这是一个神话。波兰枪骑兵没有冲锋坦克，但它显然触及了战争双方出于不同原因想要相信的某种东西。是的，波兰人想要浪漫主义的幻想，而德国人想要落后的印象，我猜是的。我的意思是，波兰人确实有骑兵，这一点绝对是真的。纳粹也有骑兵。
he describes this, the Polish cavalry as kind of Don Quixote and by extension, the whole Polish state. So that's, it's a kind of interesting ambivalence, isn't it? That it is a myth. Polish Lancers didn't charge tanks, but it obviously spoke to something that both sides in the war wanted to believe for different reasons. Yeah, the Poles, the idea of romance and the Germans, the idea of backwardness, I suppose. I mean, it's definitely true the Poles had cavalry. The Nazis had cavalry as well.
他们确实有，他们有很多马。他们的确有很多马。当他们在 1941 年进攻苏联时，他们当然带了马。还有法国，是的。是的。所以拥有骑兵并不是不合理的。但在此时，骑兵对波兰人来说意义重大，因为他们的历史传统，而且土地所有者阶层往往主导着骑兵，就像他们在英国所做的那样。但我认为，总的来说，
They did, they had a lot of horses. They did have a lot of horses. They took horses, of course, when they attacked the Soviet Union in 1941. And France, yeah. Yeah. So it's not unreasonable to have cavalry. But at this point, the cavalry mean a lot to Poles because of their historic traditions and the land owning classes tend to dominate the cavalry as of course they did in Britain. But I think that by and large
他们使用骑兵时并不愚蠢，他们知道骑兵是用来进行侦察等任务的。正如你所说，有这样一个事件，这是一个非常著名的故事，但他们根本没有在冲锋坦克。它基本上成了一场注定失败、徒劳无功的斗争的象征，这在某种程度上符合——正如你所说，它具有某种含糊性。它在不同的层面上起作用，但这可能有点误导人。我的意思是，波兰人正在努力进行一场现代战争。他们只是没有这样做的工具罢了。对的。
they used the cavalry, they knew that they weren't stupid. They used the cavalry for reconnaissance and whatnot. And there's this one incident, as you say, this very famous story, but they're not charging tanks at all. And it basically becomes an emblem of a doomed, futile struggle, which kind of suits, you know, as you say, it has a kind of ambiguity to it. It works in different ways, but it's probably a bit misleading. I mean, the Poles are trying to fight a modern war. They just don't have the tools to do it. Right.
嗯，这也凸显了机械化程度的不平衡，正是这一点注定了他们的厄运，因为基本上纳粹正在压力测试他们可以用坦克做什么，用现代飞机做什么。正如我们所知，这是毁灭性的。是的。所以在第二天，波兰人已经在节节败退，许多军官仅仅被德军推进的速度和残酷性震得精神崩溃。有一本关于第二次世界大战中波兰的绝佳书籍，作者叫扬·卡尔斯基（Jan Karski）。他当时是一名骑兵中尉。他基本上说过，在装甲部队和空军的联合打击下，只用了三个小时，就把我的师打得彻底陷入混乱。他说，到第一天结束时，
Well, also it highlights the imbalance in mechanisation, which is what dooms them because basically the Nazis are stress testing what they can do with tanks, what they can do with modern airplanes. And as we all know, it's devastating. Yeah. So by day two, the Poles are already going backwards and a lot of their officers are already shell-shocked by just the speed and the ruthlessness of the German advance. There's a brilliant book on Poland in the Second World War by a guy called Jan Karski. And he was a cavalry lieutenant. And he basically said, it took three hours for the Panzers and the Luftwaffe between them to reduce my division to complete an utter chaos. And he said, by the end of the first
我们已经不再是一支军队了。我们只是一群盲目跌撞向某个完全不明确目标的乌合之众。现在他们唯一的希望——而且并非完全是空想的希望——是他们拥有强大的朋友：英国和法国。我的意思是，英国和法国，尽管我们在过去的几集里批评过他们，但他们是严肃的玩家，你知道的，是富裕、强大的帝国，而不仅仅是某种工业民主国家。因此，波兰人抱有合理的期望，认为也许……砝码会倒向我们这一边。我们在人数上超过了德国人，而且德国人在两线作战。波兰人制定了一个名为“扎霍德计划”（Plan Zachod）的计划。该计划设想，当然，德国人会在前几天取得进展，但随后我们将撤退到波兰中部的这些易守难攻的河流防线，即维斯图拉河（Vistula）、布格河（Bug）、桑河（San）等。我们将在那里阻击德国人。
day, we weren't an army anymore. We were just a collection of random people stumbling towards some wholly indefinite goal. Now the one hope they have, and it's not a completely vain hope, they have powerful friends, Britain and France. I mean, Britain and France, for all that we have criticised them in the last few episodes, they are serious players, you know, rich, powerful empires, not just kind of industrial democracies. So the polls, it's reasonable for the polls to think, well, maybe, you know, the weight will be on our side. We outnumbered the Germans. We, we, we, they're fighting on two fronts. The polls have drawn up a plan called Plan Zachod. Now this envisages, of course, the Germans will
与此同时，在西部，法军和英军将对西德发动进攻。希特勒将不得不撤回军队，调回军队来保卫祖国。这将使我们最坏情况下稳定战线，最好情况下甚至可能发动反攻。所以从纸面上看，这听起来并不是一个多么糟糕的计划。但问题是法军和英军会尽到他们的责任吗？当 9 月 3 日英法宣战的消息传开时，华沙的大街上挤满了人，大使馆外聚集了庞大的人群，人们高歌《天佑吾王》和《马赛曲》等歌曲，场面非常感人。两天后的 9 月 5 日，波兰武装部队总司令——
make gains in the first few days, but then we will withdraw to these defensible rivers in the centre of Poland, the Vistula, the Bug, the San and so on. We will hold the Germans there. Now meanwhile in the West, the French and the British will launch their attack on Western Germany. Hitler will have to withdraw troops, recall troops to defend the fatherland. That will allow us to at worst stabilize our lines and at best maybe launch a counterattack. So on paper, it doesn't sound like such a terrible scheme. But the issue is will the French and the British do their bit? Now when the news broke that France and Britain had
一个名叫爱德华·雷兹-希姆格维（Marshal Rydz-Smigly）的元帅——他说，好吧，让我们把这个计划付诸实施吧。他们开始向国家中部撤退，现在放弃了波兰西部。他们苦苦等待、等待、等待盟友采取行动。两天后，他们得到了第一迹象，表明这将会发生。法军在三个地点进入了萨尔兰（Saarland）。
declared war on the 3rd of September, there were huge crowds in Warsaw outside the embassies, people singing, you know, God save the King and the Marseillaise and stuff, very moving scenes. Two days later on the 5th of September, the commander of the Polish Armed Forces, who's a guy called Marshal Rydz Smigli, he says, okay, let's put this planet into operation. They start to withdraw to the centre of the country, give up Western Poland now. And they're waiting and waiting and waiting for the allies to make their move. And two days later, they get the first sign this is going to happen. The French cross into the Saarland at three points.
然后，“难道就是这个时刻吗？”事实上，你知道吗？法军在深入几英里后就停了下来。这完全是个骗局。他们甚至没有到达坚固的“齐格菲防线”（Siegfried line），即德国碉堡防线。他们在那里闲逛了几个星期。然后到 10 月初，他们又撤回了法国。
And the, you know, is this it? And actually, do you know what? The French just stop a few miles in. It's a complete sham. They don't even get to the fortified Siegfried line. the, you know, is this it? And actually, do you know what? The French just stop a few miles in. It's a complete sham. They don't even get to the fortified Siegfried line, the line of kind of German forts. They hang around for a few, a couple of weeks. And then by early October, they go back to France.
而他们在西部的兵力对比占据了对德军的五比一、六比一的优势。我的意思是，就是这样。戈培尔在他的日记中写道，法军的撤退不仅仅是令人惊讶，简直是完全不可理喻。在纽伦堡审判中，约德尔将军（General Jodl）对法官们说，他在审判中表示，法军本可以在战争的头几周内占领德国。
And they, they outnumber the German forces in the West by five to one, six to one. I mean, this is the thing. Goebbels in his diary wrote, the French withdrawal is more than astonishing. It is completely incomprehensible. At the Nuremberg trials, General Jodl told the judges, he told the trial, he said the French could have taken Germany in the first weeks of the war.
他说他们在西部的兵力是我们（德军）的五倍。但他们没有这么做。不仅如此，他们没有对德国发动地面进攻，波兰人还在乞求伦敦，求求你们，英国皇家空军（RAF）什么时候去袭击德国的机场？你们什么时候开始打击德国？他们发送了直接的消息：你们什么时候打算这么做？而英国人却说，我们不想激起德国对英国的轰炸袭击。这是我们最不想做的事。我的意思是，一些英国大臣曾大言不惭地说，嗯，我们不会去轰炸德国的
He said they outnumbered us in the West by five to one. And they didn't do it. And not only do they not launch a ground invasion of Germany, the Poles are begging London, please, when are the RAF going to attack the German airfields? When are they going to start hitting Germany? And they send direct messages, when are you going to do this? And the British say, we don't want to provoke German bombing raids of Britain. That's the last thing we want to do. I mean, some British ministers notoriously said, well, we're not going to bomb German
军火工厂之类的设施。因为我的意思是，那是私有财产。你不能攻击别人的私有财产。这绝对是可耻的。所以他们唯一做的就是派皇家空军去德国上空投掷宣传传单，上面写着，你知道的，你们不应该打这场战争。你们让自己失望了。我确信，当我们顺理成章地谈到这一点时，我确信我们会的，当我们谈到“假战”（phony war）时，
munitions factories and things like that. Because I mean, that's private property. You couldn't attack people's private property. That's absolutely disgraceful. So all they do is they send the RF to drop propaganda leaflets over Germany saying, you know, you shouldn't be fighting the war. You've let yourselves down. And I'm sure we'll come to this when we, in due saying, you know, you shouldn't be fighting the war. You've let yourselves down. And I'm sure we'll come to this when we, in due course, I'm sure we will, we cover the phony war,
但它仍然是，我的意思是，这很奇怪，不是吗？为什么他们……我的意思是，这是出于心理原因吗？我认为很大程度上是心理原因。他们认为，他们假设战争将是漫长的。我认为公平地说，他们没有进行一场侵略战争的精神准备。尚武的秩序。他们没有这个。我的意思是，这完全是心理原因吗？可能不全是心理原因，但我想很大一部分是。但这太奇怪了，不是吗？因为我的意思是，波兰的战略可以说是能希望得到的最好的战略了。如果波兰作为一支军事力量能够存活下来，并且他们在西部发动进攻，那么
but it is still, I mean, it's weird, isn't it? Why are they, I mean, is it psychological reasons? I think a lot of it is psychological. They think, they assume the war will be long. They don't have the spirit, I think it's fair to say for an aggressive war. The martial order. They don't have it. I mean, is it all psychological? Probably not all psychological, but a lot of it I think is. But it's so odd, isn't it? Because I mean, the Polish strategy is the best that could have been hoped for. If the Poles do survive as a military force and they're attacking in the West, then you
就会形成希特勒一直唯恐避之不及的钳形攻势。挥霍掉这一点，实在是太奇怪了。这简直是……我的意思是，也许有些听众会想出一些复杂的理由，某种军事史上的理由，来解释这其实是一个绝妙的计划，但在我看来，这简直无法辩护。哈利克·科尚斯基在她的书《不屈之鹰》中提到，英国或法国公民给出的第一个借口是他们说，嗯，我们不想采取任何行动，因为那只会
have the pincer movement that Hitler had been so afraid of. To squander that, it just seems so odd. It's sort of, I mean, maybe some listeners will come up with some complicated reason, some sort of military history reason why this was actually a brilliant plan, but it just seemed to me pretty indefensible. Halik Khorchansky in her book, The Eagle Unbowed, she says, the first justification a British citizen of French to have is they say, well, we don't want to do anything because it'll just
激战德国人，尽管他们已经处于战争状态。然后他们的第二个借口是，他们说，我们现在不想采取任何行动，因为我们还没完全准备好。我们正在积蓄力量，给点时间吧。然后他们又等了几天，接着又说，嗯，现在采取任何行动其实也没有意义了，因为波兰无论如何都要输了。所以这就成了一个自我实现的预言。事实上确实如此。到 9 月 8 日，当盟军首脑讨论此事时，他们说，好吧，不要浪费我们的资源了。波兰显然无论如何都要输了。
provoke the Germans, even though they're at war. Then the second thing is they say, we don't want to do anything now because we're not quite ready. We're building up our forces, give it time. And then they wait a few more days and then they say, well, there's actually no point doing anything now because Poland is going to lose anyway. So it becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy. And actually it's true. On the, by the 8th of September, when allied chiefs discussed this, they say, well, that's not waste our resources. Poland's clearly going to lose anyway.
挑衅德国人，尽管他们已经在交战了。第二点是，他们说，我们现在不想采取任何行动，因为我们还没完全准备好。我们正在扩充军队，再给点时间。接着他们又等了几天，然后又说，其实现在做什么都没有意义了，因为波兰横竖都会战败。于是这就成了一个自我实现的预言。事实上也确实如此。到了9月8日盟军首脑讨论此事时，他们说，那我们就别浪费资源了。波兰显然无论如何都要战败了。
Like, let's just wait and fight a long war in the West. And that of course will be in due course, what the British will say about the French. Yeah, of course. Yeah. They're going to lose anyway. So there's no point in helping them. I mean, it becomes completely self-fulfilling. So by the second week, Poland is still all alone.
比如，我们就在西方等待并打一场漫长的战争。当然，在适当的时候，英国人也会这样对法国人说。是的，当然。是的。反正他们都会输。所以帮助他们毫无意义。我的意思是，这完全变成了一种自我实现。因此到了第二周，波兰仍然孤立无援。
And we've just come to the end of this half by talking about the situation within Poland. What makes it really, really difficult for their army is that the roads, the fields are now completely clogged with people, with untold, countless thousands of people fleeing eastwards, fleeing the German advance. Now this is an image that of course will become incredibly familiar in the years to come. And they are fleeing with very good reason, because they are facing an onslaught that in Europe, I would say, has not really been seen before, unprecedented, even by the standards of the First World War. The First World War was pretty murderous. But this is different because Hitler has set an unprecedented tone. Now remember that he does not think of the Poles as fully human as the Germans are. He specifically said to
我们刚刚通过讨论波兰国内的局势结束了前半部分。让他们军队感到极其、极其困难的是，道路和田野现在完全被人群堵塞了，成千上万、无数的人向东逃难，逃离德国人的进攻。现在，这幅画面在未来的几年里无疑会变得极其熟悉。他们逃难是有充分理由的，因为他们面临着一场在欧洲可以说是前所未见的猛烈攻击，即使以第一次世界大战的标准来看也是空前的。第一次世界大战可以说是杀戮重重。但这完全不同，因为希特勒定下了前所未有的基调。现在请记住，他不认为波兰人像德国人那样是完整的人类。他明确对
Goebbels, they are more animals than human beings, they are totally dull and formless. And that's literal, isn't it? I mean, that's his scientific opinion. Exactly. That's his scientific opinion. It's not a metaphor. He really means that. So we talked last time about this meeting he had at the Eagle's Nest before Ribbentrop went to Moscow where he briefed his generals. And I said, we'll talk about what he said in the afternoon next time. So this is what he talked about in the afternoon. In the afternoon, he said to his generals, this will be a different war from
戈培尔说过，他们与其说是人，不如说是动物，他们完全迟钝而没有成型。字面意思确实如此，对吧？我是说，那是他的科学意见。没错。那是他的科学意见。这不是隐喻。他是认真的。所以我们上次谈到了他在里宾特洛普去莫斯科之前在鹰巢开的那次会议，他在会上向他的将领们作了简报。我说过，我们下次再谈他下午说了什么。所以这就是他下午谈论的内容。下午，他对他的将领们说，这将是一场不同于
wars we've fought before. And he said, and I quote, the victor will not be asked afterwards, whether he told the truth or not. When starting and waging a war, it's not right that matters, but victory. Close your hearts to pity. Act brutally. 80 million people must obtain what's their right. Their existence must be made secure. The stronger man is right. The greatest harshness. Our strength lies in our speed and our brutality."
我们以往打过的战争的战争。他说，我引用原话：“事后没有人会问胜利者说的是不是实话。在发动和进行战争时，无关对错，只有胜利。让你们的心对怜悯冷酷起来。残酷行事。8000万人必须获得他们应有的权利。他们的生存必须得到保障。强者有理。要采取最大的严厉性。我们的力量在于我们的速度和残暴。”
And this is the analogy he chooses. Genghis Khan hunted millions of women and children to their deaths consciously and with a joyous heart. History sees in him only the great founder of a state." I'm not actually sure that's true. I think Genghis Khan's reputation is more checkered than it believes. And then he goes on to say, the aim of the war lies not in reaching particular lines, but in the physical annihilation of the enemy. By and large, people did not say that, I would say, in the First World War. Of course, people do say brutal things, but not beforehand so starkly and so coldly. He says, so in the East, I have put my death's head formations at the ready with the command to send men, women and children of Polish descent and language to their deaths, pitilessly and remorselessly.
这就是他选择的比喻：“成吉思汗有意识地、带着欢乐的心情将数百万妇女儿童赶向死亡。历史只视他为伟大的国家缔造者。”我其实不太确定这是不是真的。我认为成吉思汗的名声比这要复杂得多。接着他又说：“战争的目的不在于攻占特定的防线，而在于肉体上消灭敌人。”总的来说，在第一次世界大战中，人们是不会这样说的。当然，人们也会说一些残酷的话，但不会在事前说得如此直白和冷酷。他说：“因此，在东方，我已经让我的骷髅师整装待发，并下达了命令：无情、毫不留情地将波兰血统和语言的男女老少送上死路。
Poland must be depopulated and settled with Germans. So the generals who are listening to this, what are they making of it? Well, we know that at least one of them was appalled by it. A guy called General Kurt Liebman, he said he found it repulsive. The bragging and brash tone was downright repulsive. He said this was a bloke who had lost all feeling of responsibility and who with unsurpassed wantonness was determined to leap into the dark. This is a guy, a senior general in the Wehrmacht.
必须把波兰人口清空，并让德国人去定居。”所以正在听这番话的将领们，他们对此有何感想？嗯，我们知道至少其中一个人对此感到震惊。一个名叫库尔特·利布曼（Kurt Liebman）的将军，他说他觉得这很令人反感。那种吹嘘和狂妄的语气简直令人反感。他说这是一个已经失去了所有责任感、正以无与伦比的肆意妄为决心纵身跃入黑暗中的家伙。这是一个德军的高级将领，
This is not a kind of pacifist speaking. And Liebman said at the time he thought that a lot of other generals were quite shocked too, and thought this is all a bit strong. But they have sworn an oath to the Führer. And of course when wars start, people become radicalized very quickly. Yeah. But this is before the wars begun. Yes, of course.
这不是什么和平主义者在说话。利布曼当时还说，他认为其他许多将领也相当震惊，觉得这一切未免有点太过火了。但他们已经向元首宣誓了。当然，当战争爆发时，人们会非常迅速地变得激进。是的。但这可是在战争爆发之前。是的，当然。
That's what's striking about it. Yes. Yeah, of course. That people may well have had doubts, I think, Tom. I don't, I would be surprised if Liebman was literally the only person at that meeting of 50 people or whatever to have any question marks in his mind. Because the implication of depopulating Poland and settling it with Germans, the prospect of committing genocide, I mean, that isn't really what soldiers sign up to.
这才是最令人震惊的地方。是的。是的，当然。汤姆，我认为人们当时很可能会有疑虑。我不觉得利布曼会是那场大约有50人参加的会议上，字面意义上唯一一个心存疑念的人。因为清空波兰人口并让德国人去定居的含义，犯下种族灭绝罪行的前景，我的意思是，这并不是士兵们参军的初衷。
No. Even if you're serving Hitler. But in the context of the 1930s, after years of indoctrination, after years of listening to Hitler's speeches, fueled by a sense of resentment and victimhood. I guess you can see how it happens. I mean, we know it happened, right? It does chime with the prejudices already held by a lot of German soldiers. So we know that some German officers, when they talked to their men beforehand, they gave them pep talks.
没错。即使你是在为希特勒效劳。但在20世纪30年代的背景下，经过多年的洗脑，经过多年聆听希特勒的演讲，并在怨恨情绪和受害者心态的推波助澜下。我想你可以理解这一切是如何发生的。我的意思是，我们知道它确实发生了，对吧？这确实与许多德国士兵心中原有的偏见不谋而合。所以我们知道，一些德国军官在战前与手下谈话时，曾发表过鼓舞士气的演讲。
They said, come on, guys, we all know the polls are primitive. We all know they're dirty. They can't be trusted. We can't take any prisoners or this kind of thing. And we can see the results in two months of the campaign, hundreds of Polish villages were burned, thousands and thousands of civilians executed. Give you one example, Richard Evans in his book, The Third Reich at War, he describes a guy called Gerhard M. who was a stormtrooper who before the war was a fireman.
他们说：“得了吧，伙计们，我们都知道波兰人很落后。我们都知道他们很脏。他们不可信。我们不能留俘虏，诸如此类的话。”我们可以从两个月的战役结果中看到：数百个波兰村庄被烧毁，成千上万的平民被处决。举个例子，理查德·埃文斯在他的书《第三帝国的战争》中，描述了一个名叫格哈德·M（Gerhard M.）的人，他是一名冲锋队员，战前是一名消防员。
And he came from a place called Flensburg, which is basically Denmark. It's right on the border with Denmark. And this guy, Gerhart, describes how in the first days of the invasion, they were going through a Polish village and someone fired at them. And so they reacted by burning the entire village to the ground, burning houses, weeping women, screaming children, a picture of misery is how he described it. Gerhard described how one woman was trying to get out of her house and we stopped her, he said, and she burned to death. Her screaming rang in my ears long afterwards. And a few days later they got to another village and he said, burning houses were lining our route. Out of the flames there sounded the screams
他来自一个叫弗伦斯堡（Flensburg）的地方，那里基本上就是丹麦。它紧挨着丹麦边境。这个叫格哈德的家伙描述了在入侵的头几天，他们穿过一个波兰村庄时，有人向他们开枪。于是他们的反应是将整个村庄夷为平地，燃烧的房屋、哭泣的妇女、尖叫的儿童，他将此描述为一幅悲惨的画面。格哈德描述说，一个女人试图从屋里出来，我们阻止了她，他说，她被活活烧死了。她的尖叫声过了很久还在我耳边回响。几天后，他们到了另一个村庄，他说，沿途都是燃烧的房屋。火焰中传出了尖叫声，
of the people who had hidden in them and were unable anymore to rescue themselves. It was dreadful. It's still ringing in my ears even today, but they shot at us and so they deserve death. So that is conscience being put in the shade by fascist ideology. I guess so, by fascist ideology, by the pressure of war. And the thing is, this is within the, this is in the first week of the war. Right. I mean, I know that soldiers who get shot at commit atrocities, but they don't justify it, I think, in the way that he is. Yeah. I think this is different from, let's say, the French troops in the Peninsula War or something.
那是藏在里面、再也无法自救的人们的尖叫声。太可怕了。直到今天，那种声音还在我的耳边回响，但他们向我们开枪了，所以他们罪有应得。因此，这是良知在法西斯意识形态面前黯然失色。我想是的，在法西斯意识形态和战争压力的作用下。问题是，这发生在……这发生在战争的第一周。没错。我的意思是，我知道遭到枪击的士兵会犯下暴行，但他们不会以他这种方式来为此辩解。是的。我认为这不同于，比方说半岛战争中的法军之类的情况。
Right. Or the Germans in Belgium in 1914. Yeah, or British soldiers in the Burr War or whatever it might be. I mean, there are so many, there are countless examples, but this has been ideologically prepared for. The Supreme Commander, the guy at the top, has briefed his people beforehand and said, you know, kill them all. This is what I want to do. People did not do that before the First World War. I mean, people say brutal things in wars and they give brutal instructions, of course. But this is of a different order and all the historians of the Third Reich and the Second World War. It's ideological programming, isn't it?
或者1914年在比利时的德国人。是的，或者布尔战争中的英国士兵等等。我的意思是，有太多、数不清的例子，但这已经是经过意识形态预热的。最高指挥官、处于权力顶端的那个人事先向他的人手交了底，说：“你知道的，把他们全杀了。这就是我想做的事。”在第一次世界大战之前，人们是不会这样做的。我的意思是，人们在战争中会说残酷的话，也会下达残酷的指令，这是当然的。但这是完全不同性质的，所有第三帝国和第二次世界大战的历史学家都这么认为。这是意识形态编程，对吧？
Exactly. Well, here's the thing, right? Because it's not just the army that are doing it. It's also the SS. So this is the really ominous thing. That in their wake are following the first Einsatzgruppen under Reinhard Heydrich task forces they are sent in their wake are following the first Einsatzgruppen under Reinhard Heydrich task forces. They are sent in the wake of the army to carry out the SS's ideological vision. These are led by experienced guys who had often been in the Freikorps in the 1920s, the right-wing paramilitaries. Right from the start they have been sent to round up, to find, to execute government officials, intellectuals, officers and so on. They are killing about 200 people a day in the first
没错。嗯，问题就在这里，对吧？因为不只是军队在这样做。党卫军也在这样做。所以这才是真正不祥的事情。紧随他们身后的，是由赖因哈德·海德里希（Reinhard Heydrich）率领的第一批别动队。他们被派往军队身后，去执行党卫军的意识形态愿景。这些别动队由经验丰富的人领导，他们通常在20世纪20年代参加过自由军团（Freikorps）——那些右翼准军事组织。从一开始，他们就被派去搜捕、搜寻并处决政府官员、知识分子、军官等。在入侵的第一周，
week of the invasion. And Heydrich is shocked at this and says, this is far too few. This is, we should be killing far more people. On the 19th of September, he had a meeting with General Halder commanding the German army. And Heydrich said, come on, I want to have a clear out Jews, intelligentsia, priesthood, aristocracy. He says, I, my men have got lists with 60,000 people's names on all of those 60,000 people have to go. So decapitation. Yeah, decapitation strategy. Now, of course, the category of people as well that jumps out at you from that is, since we know what's going to happen, are Poland's Jews. Poland has by far the largest Jewish population in Europe, about three and a half million
他们每天大约杀害200人。海德里希对此感到震惊，并表示：“这实在太少了。这……我们应该杀更多的人。”9月19日，他与指挥德国军队的哈尔德将军（General Halder）举行了会晤。海德里希说：“来吧，我想做一次大清洗：犹太人、知识分子、神职人员、贵族。”他说：“我、我的人手里有长达6万人的名单，所有这6万人必须全部清除。”也就是斩首战略。是的，斩首战略。现在，当然，从那一长串名单中跳出来的另一类人，既然我们知道接下来会发生什么，那就是波兰的犹太人。波兰拥有欧洲迄今为止最大的犹太人口，大约有350万
people, which is a tenth of the population. They live in the cities by and large, so Warsaw, Łódź, Krakow and so on. They are very identifiable. So in Nazi antisemitic cartoons, Jews will be portrayed as wearing a distinctive style of dress, wear their beards, their hair in a distinctive way. Even though most German Jews do not look like this, but in Poland, lots of Jews do. I mean, they look, you can tell them apart from the Gentile population. Absolutely right. Which means that they're then sitting ducks to Germans who have been prepared to look
人，占总人口的十分之一。他们大都住在城市里，比如华沙、罗兹、克拉科夫等等。他们极易辨认。因此在纳粹的反犹漫画中，犹太人通常被描绘成穿着独特的服饰，留着独特的胡须和发型。尽管大多数德国犹太人并不长这样，但在波兰，许多犹太人都这样。我的意思是，他们的外表……你能把他们和非犹太人区分开来。完全正确。这意味着他们成了任由那些准备用厌恶目光看待他们的德国人宰割的羔羊。
on them with horror. Absolutely right. They are immediately identifiable in a way they might not be in Germany, in the Reich itself. So absolutely they live in the cities, they have distinctive clothes, they have distinctive kind of hair, they speak Yiddish as the first language. Most Polish Jews are very poor, so they live in a part of town that's maybe a bit more run down, which of course then plays into the Nazi stereotype again. Now we don't need to massively dwell on this because it's so horrific, but we know that right from the very beginning, and it's not just the SS, it's ordinary German soldiers
完全正确。他们能被一眼认出，这在德国或第三帝国本土可能是做不到的。所以绝对没错，他们住在城市里，穿着独特的衣服，留着独特发型，把意第绪语作为第一语言。大多数波兰犹太人都非常贫困，所以他们住在城镇里可能比较破旧的地区，这当然又迎合了纳粹的刻板印象。现在我们不需要在这个问题上过多纠缠，因为它太可怕了，但我们知道从一开始，不仅是党卫军，连普通的德国士兵
as well, as they pass through towns, they will go into the Jewish areas, they will round people up, they will shoot randomly into houses, they will mutilate people, they will humiliate the women and children, they will do all these kinds of things. I mean, you know, there are horrific scenes from the outset. There is no question about kind of where this is ultimately all leading. Ian Kershaw and his biography of Hitler, he identifies in the first week of September, 1939 is the point where they cross that kind of moral line. I mean, he calls it, Tom, the Nazi Rubicon, the moment they really cross the line. So the moral Rubicon.
也是如此，当他们穿过城镇时，会闯入犹太人聚居区，搜捕人们，向房屋盲目开枪，残害他人，羞辱妇女儿童，他们会做所有这些类似的事情。我的意思是，你知道，从一开始就有极其可怕的场面。毫无疑问，这一切最终将通向何方。伊恩·克肖（Ian Kershaw）在其希特勒传记中指出，1939年9月的第一周，就是他们跨越那种道德底线的时刻。我的意思是，他称之为“纳粹卢比孔河”，汤姆，也就是他们真正越过那条线的时刻。所以，是道德的卢比孔河。
Yeah, moral Rubicon. It's up to this point, Hitler has done terrible, terrible things within Germany, but by and large, not always, of course, but by and large, there has been a sort of pathetic, flimsy legal framework like the Nuremberg Laws. And you know, colossal quantities of people have not been murdered at this point, as in hundreds of thousands of people have not been murdered at this point, as in hundreds of thousands of people. But from this point, they are clearly envisaging killing gigantic numbers of people. So as he says, this is not yet genocide. It is not yet the all out genocide that you see when
是的，道德的卢比孔河。在此之前，希特勒在德国国内做过极其可怕的事情，但大体上——当然并非总是如此——大体上，还有一套可怜的、脆弱的法律框架，比如《纽伦堡法案》。你知道，当时还没有谋杀海量的人，也就是没有谋杀成百上千万人。但在那之后，他们显然在设想屠杀数量庞大的人。正如他所说，这还不是种族灭绝。这还不是你在1941年他们开进俄国时所看到的那种全力以赴的种族灭绝。但是，我引用原话：“它具有接近种族灭绝的特征。它是接下来将要发生的事情的试验场。”所以，这是一种……
they go into Russia in 1941. But, and I quote, it had near genocidal traits. It was the training ground for what was to follow. So it is the, um, the kind of neo-Darwinian, social Darwinian nightmare of how nature functions are untrammeled by moral considerations. It is the predation of the strong upon the weak. Yes. And not all German officers are comfortable with it. So there's a guy called Colonel General Johannes Blaszkiewicz, who is a Wehrmacht commander in Poland. And two months into this,
可以说是新达尔文主义的、社会达尔文主义的噩梦，关于自然如何在不受道德考量约束的情况下运作。这是强者对弱者的掠夺。是的。并非所有的德国军官都对此感到心安理得。所以有一个叫约翰内斯·布拉斯科维茨（Johannes Blaskiewicz）的上将，他是德军在波兰的一名指挥官。两个月后，
so November 1939, he wrote a report and he said, I'm absolutely appalled by what we've done. By the animal and pathological instincts of the SS. He said we have murdered tens of thousands of Jews and Polish civilians. And he said, if we don't bring the SS under control now, remember this is just two months into the Second World War, there will be an immeasurable brutalization of moral debasement. And his superiors were kind of, they thought thiske's lost his marbles. They basically buried his report. He persisted.
也就是1939年11月，他写了一份报告，说：“我对我们所做的事情感到彻底震惊。对党卫军的动物性和病态本能感到震惊。”他说我们已经谋杀了成千上万的犹太人和波兰平民。他说，如果我们现在不把党卫军控制住——请记住，这仅仅是第二次世界大战开始两个月后——将会有不可估量的道德野蛮化和堕落。而他的上级则认为，这个家伙简直疯了。他们基本上把他的报告给压下了。但他坚持不懈。
Hitler was told about it, and Hitler just said very contemptuously, you can't wage war with Salvation Army methods. And Blazkowicz was the only senior commander who wasn't promoted after the conquest of Poland. He basically denied promotion. He was brought back later on, but his career kind of stalled. And actually he ended up taking his own life at the Nuremberg trials. And he was going to be acquitted. He was put on trial at Nuremberg and he jumped out of a window, killed himself.
希特勒得知此事后，轻蔑地表示：“你不能用救世军的方法来打仗。”而布拉斯科维茨是征服波兰后唯一没有晋升的高级指挥官。他基本上被剥夺了晋升资格。他后来被重新启用，但他的职业生涯陷入了停滞。事实上，他最后在纽伦堡审判期间自杀了。他本会被无罪释放的。他在纽伦堡受审时，从窗户跳下去自杀了。
And the judges and everybody were very surprised because they said, we were going to, not only were we going to acquit him, we were going to say he was how the German army should have behaved. Right. He was clearly so traumatized, traumatized by guilt and honour. Anyway, back to the narrative. All the time the Germans are grinding Eastwards. On the 7th of September, the Poles move their high command to the far East of the country to Brest, because they realized that the Warsaw
法官和其他所有人都非常震惊，因为他们说：“我们不仅打算判他无罪，我们还打算说他才是德国军队应有的表现。”没错。他显然受到了极大的创伤，被内疚和荣誉感所创伤。不管怎样，回到正题。德国人一直在向东推进。9月7日，波兰人将他们的最高指挥部迁到了该国最东部的布列斯特，因为他们意识到华沙
is next in the firing line. Their communications network has fallen apart. Their defensive plan is in a complete and utter mess. And the next day, the eighth of September, the German Panzers reach the outskirts of Warsaw. Okay. Well, let's take a break there with the German army approaching the Polish capital and in the second half, we will see what ensues. We're approaching the Polish capital and in the second half we will see what ensues.
将是下一个遭到攻击的目标。他们的通讯网络已经崩溃。他们的防御计划一团糟。第二天，即9月8日，德国装甲部队抵达了华沙郊区。好吧，随着德国军队逼近波兰首都，我们就在这里休息一下，在后半部分，我们将看到接下来会发生什么。我们正在逼近波兰首都，在后半部分，我们将看到接下来会发生什么。
This episode is brought to you by NordVPN. Dominic, what do you find useful about NordVPN? Well, Tom, as you know, I am absolutely passionate about NordVPN. One of the things I love about them is their Threat Protection Pro, an absolutely brilliant antivirus tool. It is so effective and so powerful. It is integrated directly into the NordVPN app. So what it does is it protects you from phishing and other cyber threats. And the brilliant thing about it is it allows you to browse safely and smoothly.
本集由 NordVPN 赞助播出。多米尼克，你觉得 NordVPN 有什么好用的地方？嗯，汤姆，如你所知，我对 NordVPN 充满热情。我最喜欢的功能之一是他们的威胁防护 Pro（Threat Protection Pro），这是一款绝对出色的杀毒工具。它非常有效，功能极其强大。它直接整合到了 NordVPN 应用中。所以它的作用是保护你免受网络钓鱼和其他网络威胁的侵害。最棒的是，它能让你安全、顺畅地浏览网页。
And Dominic, I know you're all about cyber security, so you know better than anyone. It can often be very hard to distinguish fake websites from real ones but the great news is that threat protection pro will prevent you from accessing them and you know what NordVPN is actually the first and only VPN app to receive the certification that their anti-phishing software is reliable. That's one of the things that make me so passionate about NordVPN. So to stay secure online you really should take is reliable. receive a bonus four months on top of your plan. And there is no risk with Nord's 30-day money back guarantee. The link is also in the episode description box. Calling all sellers.
多米尼克，我知道你一直很关注网络安全，所以你比任何人都清楚。通常很难区分假网站和真网站，但好消息是，威胁防护 Pro 会阻止你访问这些网站。你知道吗，NordVPN 实际上是第一个也是唯一一个获得其反网络钓鱼软件可靠性认证的 VPN 应用。这就是我对 NordVPN 充满热忱的原因之一。因此，为了保持在线安全，你真的应该采取……是可靠的。您的套餐可额外获得四个月的奖励。此外，Nord 还提供 30 天退款保证，没有任何风险。链接也在本集简介栏中。呼叫所有销售人员。
Salesforce is hiring account executives to join us on the cutting edge of technology. Here, innovation isn't a buzzword. It's a way of life. You'll be solving customer challenges faster with agents, winning with purpose, and showing the world what AI was meant to be. Let's create the agent-first future together. Head to salesforce.com slash careers to learn more. Hi, it's Cathy Kay here from The Rest Is Politics US.
Salesforce 正在招聘客户高管，邀请他们加入我们的技术前沿。在这里，创新不是一个流行语。它是一种生活方式。你将利用智能体更快地解决客户难题，带着使命赢得胜利，并向世界展示人工智能本该有的样子。让我们一起创造以智能体为先的未来。前往 salesforce.com/careers 了解更多信息。嗨，我是凯蒂·凯（Cathy Kay），来自《The Rest Is Politics US》。
We felt at this time as America is heading into the Trump administration that we should look back on one of the darkest moments in recent American history. So we have done just that with a series on Trump's insurrection and his attempts back in 2020 to steal the election from Joe Biden. There was an incitement of an insurrection. They stormed the Capitol. They literally have senators running for their lives. We break it down.
我们觉得在这个美国即将迎来特朗普政府的时刻，我们应该回顾一下美国近代史上最黑暗的时刻之一。所以我们通过一个系列节目做到了这一点，内容关于特朗普的叛乱以及他在 2020 年试图从乔·拜登手中窃取大选的行径。这是一次对叛乱的煽动。他们冲进了国会大厦。他们甚至让参议员们仓皇逃命。我们对此进行了剖析。
We give an hour by hour of all the incidents, the fences smashing, the windows breaking, gunshots firing, Trump supporters smoking joints in statutory hall. Just imagine the bedlam and incredibly some of these people are going to be pardoned by Mr. Trump. And so January 6th, I've never told Cady K this, but January 6th is my birthday. Okay, tune in and listen. Yeah, that's not the only extraordinary thing
我们按小时详细梳理了所有的事件：围栏被砸碎、窗户被打破、枪声响起、特朗普的支持者们在雕像大厅里抽大麻。试想一下那场混乱，难以置信的是，其中一些人居然将获得特朗普先生的特赦。所以，1月6日——我从来没告诉过凯蒂·凯这一点——但1月6日是我的生日。好了，收听并关注吧。是的，这并不是关于1月6日这个日期的唯一非同寻常之处。
about the date of January the 6th, however. I mean, this is why this story and this series is so important and so gripping, because so many of these characters are coming back with us today. And so much has been forgiven and swept under the carpet, and America decided in the election last year that they were going to reinstate Donald Trump.
然而，我的意思是，这就是为什么这个故事和这个系列如此重要且引人入胜，因为其中许多角色今天又回到了我们身边。而且有那么多事情被原谅、被掩盖，美国人在去年的大选中决定让唐纳德·特朗普卷土重来。
With that, there really is no better time to take a look at these events. To hear more, just search the rest is politics US wherever you get your podcasts, hear a clip from this mini series at the end of this week's episode. Hello, welcome back to The Rest is History and we're listening to the invasion, the conquest, the rape of Poland and Dominic. The Germans have reached the outskirts of Warsaw. How does the city respond? Heroically, I think, Tom, in a word, we heard from the mayor Stefan Starzynski at the very beginning.
有鉴于此，现在真的是回顾这些事件的最佳时机。想了解更多信息，只需在您获取播客的任何地方搜索“The Rest is Politics US”，并在本期节目的最后收听该迷你系列的片段。你好，欢迎回到《The Rest is History》，我们将收听关于入侵、征服、对波兰的强占的节目，多米尼克。德国人已经抵达了华沙郊区。这座城市是如何回应的？简而言之，汤姆，表现得非常英勇，我们一开始就听到了市长斯特凡·斯塔任斯基（Stefan Starzynski）的讲话。
He musters the population of the city to dig anti-tank ditches and to put up barricades and all this stuff. And they actually do hold off the first German attack. The Germans surround, they then surround the city with infantry and with panzers. And Hitler says, we will starve and bomb and pummel it into submission. The Poles asked the Germans, they sent a message saying can we at least evacuate our civilian population and the Germans said no, no way. So on the 10th of September Warsaw became the first capital in Europe to be subjected to relentless bombing raids. We'll come to them in a second. The city
他动员城市居民挖掘反坦克壕沟、设置路障等等。他们确实挡住了德国的第一波进攻。德国人用步兵和装甲部队包围了这座城市。希特勒说：“我们将通过饥饿、轰炸和猛烈攻击迫使其投降。”波兰人要求德国人——他们发了一条消息说，我们至少可以疏散平民吗？而德国人回答说：“不，没门。”因此，在9月10日，华沙成为欧洲第一个遭受无休止轰炸的首都。我们一会儿就会讲到这些。这座城市
held out for another week but meanwhile there is a devastating twist coming, isn't there, which was being prepared in our previous episode. So it becomes a total surprise to our listeners what now happens. But it does come as a surprise to the Poles because the Poles of course don't know what was decided in Moscow. Stalin has been biding his time for two weeks. He's been distracted because the Red Arm has actually been fighting the Japanese in the Far East, a place called Khalkhin Gol in Mongolia, not really reported in the West at all, but very important in the long run because it actually persuades the Japanese to switch their attention from fighting the Russians to fighting further south in Asia. Anyway, when that's all
又坚守了一个星期，但与此同时，一个毁灭性的转折即将到来，不是吗？我们在上一集中已经为此做好了铺垫。所以这让我们的听众对接下来发生的事情感到非常意外。但这确实让波兰人感到意外，因为波兰人当然不知道莫斯科达成了什么协议。斯大林一直在养精蓄锐，静观其变。他一直分心，因为红军实际上一直在远东与日本人作战，那是在蒙古一个叫诺门罕（Khalkhin Gol）的地方，西方几乎没有对此进行报道，但从长远来看非常重要，因为它实际上说服了日本人将注意力从与俄国人作战转移到向亚洲南部进一步扩张。无论如何，当这一切
over, on the morning of the 17th of September, Molotov, his foreign minister, calls the Polish ambassador in Moscow and says to him, Poland is clearly disintegrated. Poland is dead. Poland is full of our Ukrainian and Belarusian kith and kin, and we feel honor bound to protect them, and therefore we're sending in the Red Army. And this is a very familiar argument to the Poles, as Halik Kowalski says in her book. It's the same argument the Russians had used in 1795 to justify the third partition of Poland. So the Polish ambassador thinks, oh, here we go again. Yeah, exactly. The Red Army crossed the border immediately, almost 40 divisions in total coming from Belarus and Ukraine. The Poles were staggered. The Poles didn't know how to react. Are they coming
结束时，在9月17日早晨，他的外交部长莫洛托夫致电波兰驻莫斯科大使，对他说：“波兰显然已经土崩瓦解。波兰已经死了。波兰到处都是我们的乌克兰和白俄罗斯同胞，我们感到有责任保护他们，因此我们正派红军开拔。”对于波兰人来说，这是一个非常熟悉的论点，正如哈利克·科瓦尔斯基（Halik Kowalski）在其书中所说。这与俄国人在1795年用来为第三次瓜分波兰辩护的论点如出一辙。所以波兰大使心想：“哦，又来了。”是的， exatamente（没错）。红军立即越过了边界，来自白俄罗斯和乌克兰的近40个师齐头并进。波兰人惊呆了。波兰人不知所措。他们是来
to help us? Are they coming to attack us? Even many Soviet soldiers themselves were actually not sure which shades Putin's invasion of Ukraine. Are we the goodies? Are we the baddies? Yeah, what side they're on. The Polish commander said to them don't resist, you know, it's pointless to fall back and actually at this point the Polish commander say to their army we need to actually get out of Poland to save the army so they start to retreat south towards the Romanian border. The British and the French are staggered by this. So they had no inkling that it was coming. They didn't. They didn't know it was coming at all. The fabled British spy service has yet not covered itself in glory. Do you know
帮我们的吗？他们是来进攻我们的吗？甚至许多苏联士兵自己其实也不确定这与普京入侵乌克兰如出一辙。我们是好人吗？我们是坏人吗？是的，他们到底是哪一边的。波兰指挥官对他们说：“不要抵抗，你知道的，向后撤退毫无意义。”其实就在此时，波兰指挥官对他们的军队说：“我们需要离开波兰以保存军队。”于是他们开始向南朝着罗马尼亚边境撤退。英法两国对此惊呆了。所以他们对此毫无预兆。他们真的不知道。他们根本不知道这会发生。大名鼎鼎的英国情报机构再次没有建立什么丰功伟绩。你知道
who really lets himself down here, Tom? Somebody who you know I don't hold in high regard. This will not go down well with our Welsh listeners. It's David Lloyd George. Lloyd George had never been a friend of Poland, going right back to the 1920s. He's basically opposed Poland at every point. And Lloyd George wrote an article in the Sunday Express, later the home of AJB Taylor, saying the Soviet Union is completely within its rights. You know, it's completely reasonable for the Soviet Union to take its historic lands in Eastern Poland. I mean, I think this is really, really poor stuff from Lloyd George. Well, Lloyd George is one of the guys who's being, I mean, in due course, he'll be lined
在这里真正让自己丢脸的是谁吗？汤姆？一个你知道我并不看重的人。这在我们的威尔士听众听来可能会很不舒服。这就是大卫·劳埃德·乔治（David Lloyd George）。劳埃德·乔治从20世纪20年代开始就从来不是波兰的朋友。他基本上在每一个节点都反对波兰。劳埃德·乔治在《星期日快报》（后来成为 A·J·B·泰勒的阵地）上发表了一篇文章，称苏联完全有权这么做。你知道的，苏联夺回其在波兰东部的历史领土是完全合理的。我的意思是，我认为劳埃德·乔治的这种言论真的是烂透了。嗯，劳埃德·乔治正是那些——我的意思是，假以时日，他会被视作
up as a potential Marshal Pétain, won't he? Mateo Pétain, yeah. I mean, I know that some people love Lloyd George, but I think he's a terrible man. Because most people in Britain were just so appalled by Stalin's behavior. They, Chamberlain, you know, talked in the Commons of his horror. His assistant private secretary, Jock Colville, wrote in his diary, said it was an act of unparalleled greed and immorality. The Soviet justification, the most revolting document in modern history. But of course, what are they going to do? The answer is nothing. If they haven't done anything against Germany, they're hardly going to intervene against the Soviet Union. So for the Poles,
潜在的贝当元帅（Marshal Pétain），对吧？菲利普·贝当，是的。我的意思是，我知道有些人很喜欢劳埃德·乔治，但我认为他是个糟糕透顶的人。因为英国的大多数人都对斯大林的行径感到无比震惊。张伯伦（Chamberlain）你知道的，在下议院表达了他的震惊。他的私人助理秘书乔克·科尔维尔（Jock Colville）在日记中写道，这是一场无与伦比的贪婪与不道德的行为。苏联的辩解是现代历史上最令人作呕的文件。但当然，他们能做什么呢？答案是：什么都不做。如果他们对德国都没有采取任何行动，他们就更不会干涉苏联了。所以对波兰人来说，
this is really the death knell. Their leadership flees into Romania. Later, that scene is very controversial. You know, they're capitalists still holding out. Why have they fled to Romania? I guess they're damned if they do, damned if they don't really. So now the dictators are free to carve up Poland between them. The 19th of September, two days later, Hitler entered Danzig and triumph. Usual scenes. Yeah. Flowers, Nazi salutes. He spent a week at a hotel, the casino hotel. We know that Hitler loves the hotel. Does it have a spa?
这真的是丧钟敲响。他们的领导层逃往了罗马尼亚。后来，那一幕备受争议。你知道的，他们的资本家还在苦苦支撑。为什么他们要逃往罗马尼亚？我想他们横竖都是死，怎么做都不对。所以现在两个独裁者可以自由瓜分波兰了。9月19日，两天后，希特勒胜利进入但泽。一如既往的场面。是的。鲜花、纳粹礼。他在一家名为赌场酒店（Casino Hotel）的酒店住了一周。我们知道希特勒很喜欢这家酒店。它有水疗中心吗？
Probably does have a spa. It's a seaside resort called Sopop, which is just outside Gdansk. And he took twice, took flights to Warsaw to watch the bombing of Warsaw firsthand. And he loved it. Kershaw describes in his biography how much Hitler enjoyed. He loved war and he loved watching it. He must have felt like a god on Valhalla, sweeping over the scene of devastating battle or something. An analogy that he would have enjoyed, I'm sorry to say. What's happening to Warsaw is
可能确实有水疗中心。这是一个名为索波特（Sopot）的海滨度假胜地，就在格但斯克郊外。他曾两次乘飞机前往华沙，亲眼观看对华沙的轰炸。他非常喜欢。克肖在传记中描述了希特勒是多么享受这一切。他热爱战争，也热爱观看战争。他当时一定觉得自己就像瓦尔哈拉神殿里的神一样，俯瞰着毁灭性的战场景象或类似的东西。一个他会喜欢的比喻，我很遗憾地这么说。华沙正在发生的事情是
at this point, I think it's fair to say unprecedented in European history. Of course there have been bombings in Spain, but not of a capital city on a scale like this. The city is being pounded by artillery every day, endless incendiary bombs from the skies, stukas swooping overhead, machine gunning people. Almost all of the city's hospitals have been demolished or on fire. There's no electricity. Lots of places, there's no water. The streets are full of bodies or dead horses and rubble. And the most common comparison people say, this is how I thought the end of the world would be. You know, this is the only thing that can possibly spring to mind. To mark Hitler's second flight on the 25th of September, the Luftwaffe really turned
在这个时候，我认为可以公平地说，这在欧洲历史上是空前的。当然，西班牙曾有过轰炸，但没有对一个首都进行过如此规模的轰炸。这座城市每天都遭到炮火轰击，天空中落下无尽的燃烧弹，斯图卡轰炸机在头顶俯冲，用机枪扫射人群。几乎所有城市的医院都被摧毁或陷入火海。没有电力。很多地方没有水。街道上到处都是尸体、死马和瓦砾。人们最常说的一个比喻是：“这就是我想象中世界末日的样子。”你知道的，这是唯一能让人脑海中浮现的画面。为了纪念希特勒的第二次飞行，在9月25日，德国空军（Luftwaffe）真正加紧了
the screw. They sent wave after wave of bombers, just indiscriminately hitting apartment blocks, schools, hospitals. At the end, there was so much fire, so much smoke that they basically had to call off the attack because they couldn't see what they were doing. There were just clouds and clouds of black smoke. Most people at this stage had run out of food. Hundreds and hundreds of people are trapped in the ruins of these buildings. If you want to get a sense of it, I mean, why would you? But if you do, there's
攻势。他们派遣了一波又一波的轰炸机，不加区分地轰炸公寓楼、学校、医院。最后，大火和浓烟实在太多，他们基本上不得不取消进攻，因为他们根本看不清自己在干什么。到处都是一片又一片的黑烟。大多数人在这个阶段已经断粮了。成百上千的人被困在这些建筑物的废墟中。如果你想感受一下——我的意思是，你为什么要呢？但如果你真的想，有一部
a brilliant documentary film, very short film called Siege by an American photographer, Julian Bryan, who was basically the last Western journalist in Warsaw. When you go to the museums in Gdansk and Warsaw, they've always got this kind of playing and it's extraordinarily kind of harrowing. I'll just read one eyewitness account to give you a sense of the novelty of it. So that's the important thing is the scene that we're used to now from wartime footage, but the time was the first time it had happened. And this is from a guy called General Stanislaw Sozabowski.
非常出色的纪录片，一部由美国摄影师朱利安·布赖恩（Julian Bryan）拍摄的非常短的纪录片，名叫《围困》（Siege），他是当时华沙最后一位西方记者。当你去格但斯克和华沙的博物馆时，他们总是在播放这个片段，它有一种异常揪心的效果。我只读一段目击者的陈述，让你们感受一下这种新奇感。所以重要的事情是，这种场景是我们现在从战时影像中习以为常的，但在当时，这是头一次发生。这段话来自一位名叫斯坦尼斯瓦夫·索扎博夫斯基（Stanislaw Sosabowski）的将军。
Now he actually ended up at Arnhem, a bridge too far. Do you know what? He was played by Gene Hackman in the film. Goodness. So imagine Gene Hackman telling you this. I was not expecting Gene Hackman to make an appearance. No, no, it was always great to get him into the show. He said, I had seen death and destruction in many forms, but never had I seen such mass destruction which hit everyone regardless
他后来其实参加了阿纳姆战役，也就是那部《遥远的桥》。你知道吗？他在电影里是由吉恩·哈克曼（Gene Hackman）扮演的。天哪。所以想象一下吉恩·哈克曼在对你诉说这一切。我真没想到吉恩·哈克曼会出场。不，不，把他的名字带进节目里总是很棒的。他说：“我曾见过各种形式的死亡和破坏，但我从未见过如此大规模的破坏，它打击了每一个人，不论其无辜与否。
of innocence or guilt. Gone were the proud buildings of churches, museums and art galleries. Statues of famous men who fought for our freedom lay smashed to pieces at the bases of their plinths, or stood decapitated and shells scarred. The parks created for their beauty and for the happy sounds of laughing playing children were empty and torn, the lawns dotted with the bare mounds of hurried graves. Almost the only noise was the rumble of bricks as walls weakened by bombs finally subsided. The smell of burning houses pillared into a windless sky and the smell of putrefaction lingered in the notches. And if you juxtapose that with the reading that we began the episode with, you know, one of them is Warsaw's glory
曾经引以为傲的教堂、博物馆和美术馆的建筑消失了。为我们的自由而战的著名人物的雕像粉身碎骨地倒在基座上，或者头颅落地、伤痕累累。那些为美景和欢声笑语、嬉戏儿童而建的公园空无一人、满目疮痍，草坪上点缀着一个个匆忙掩埋死者的光秃秃的土丘。几乎唯一的噪音就是因炸弹而变弱的墙壁最终坍塌时的砖块轰鸣声。燃烧房屋的气味化作滚滚浓烟直冲无风的天空，空气中弥漫着腐烂的气味。”如果你把这段文字与我们节目开头朗读的内容放在一起对比，你知道的，其中一个是华沙的荣耀，
and the other is a much more unsentimental, this is actually the reality of what it's like in the streets. So Warsaw finally surrendered on the afternoon of the 27th. Its soldiers who defended it, 100,000 people were led to POW camps. The Nazi vengeance inevitably fell on the afternoon of the 27th. Its soldiers who defended it, 100,000 people were led to POW camps. The Nazi vengeance inevitably fell on the city's Jewish population. That was a third of the population, about 350,000 people. Their shops and houses looted. People are beaten up or killed in the streets. Women humiliated, stripped, raped, all of this kind of thing. I mean, it's a horrendous, horrendous scene. The news of Poland's defeat back in Germany, there was no triumph actually. There was no victory parade because of course the war wasn't over. They're still technically
而另一个则更加不带感情色彩，这才是街道上真实的样子。所以华沙最终在27日下午投降了。防守它的士兵，10万名官兵被带往战俘营。纳粹的复仇不可避免地降临到了这座城市的犹太人头上。那是占人口三分之一的人口，大约35万。他们的店铺和房屋被洗劫一空。人们在街头遭到殴打或杀害。妇女受辱、被剥光衣服、遭强奸，所有诸如此类的事情。我的意思是，这是一个极其、极其恐怖的场面。关于波兰战败的消息传回德国时，实际上并没有什么凯旋。没有举办胜利游行，因为战争当然还没结束。从技术上讲，他们仍在
fighting Britain and France. And actually, the people who were in Berlin, they said, you know, nothing's really changed. You know, there's a bit of rationing, but otherwise nothing has changed. So William Shire, the journalist, American journalist, who you've quoted a fair bit, he said, for most people, the war was something they just read about in the newspapers. It was unreal. He has an amazing description of being on the subway and loads of women late at night get on the opera house. He's struck by the incongruity of the fact they're all nattering about the opera they've just seen. And he knows that at the time, German bombs are falling on Warsaw and
与英法作战。实际上，身在柏林的人们说：“你知道的，其实一切都没有改变。有一点配给制，但除此之外一切照旧。”所以威廉·夏伊勒（William Shirer），那位你经常引用的美国记者，他说，对大多数人来说，战争只是他们在报纸上读到的东西。这很不真实。他有一段精彩的描述：有一次他坐地铁，深夜有很多妇女在歌剧院上车。他惊讶于一个不合情宜的事实：她们都在喋喋不休地谈论她们刚看过的歌剧。而他深知，此时此刻，德国炸弹正落在华沙，
they don't mention it at all. And he said, I doubt if anything short of an awful bombing or years of semi-starvation will bring home the war to the people here, which was very pressing because that is what will come to Berlin. A week later, nine days later, 20th September, he described how he hadn't met anybody who thought there was anything wrong with what the Germans were doing in Poland. Do they know what's happening in Poland though? They know they're fighting a war. But they don't know the full scale of what's being visited on the Poles. They don't know the scale of it, but people, I guess, eventually word will filter back.
而她们对此闭口不谈。他说：“我怀疑，除了可怕的轰炸或长期的半饥饿状态之外，没有什么能让这里的普通民众真正切实体会到战争的滋味。”这非常有远见，因为这正是将要降临到柏林头上的命运。一周后，九天后的9月20日，他描述说，他还没有遇到过任何人觉得德国人在波兰做的事有什么不对。不过，他们知道波兰发生了什么吗？他们知道他们在打仗。但他们不知道对波兰人施加暴行的全部规模。他们不知道其规模有多大，但我想，消息最终还是会渗透回来。
I mean, this is a huge question in and of itself, of course, isn't it, Tom? There should be a whole podcast. How much did the ordinary German people know about what was being done in their name? But I'm just wondering whether Nazi propaganda celebrates what's being done in Poland or whether it keeps quiet about it. I think obviously it disguises a huge amount of what they're doing. I mean, they're not saying we're bombing hospitals, we've set schools on fire, we've burned people alive in their villages. I mean, they're definitely not doing that. So yes, reasonably, you can say they don't know about that. But even so,
我的意思是，这本身就是一个巨大的问题，不是吗，汤姆？这应该做成一整期播客。普通德国民众对以他们名义所做的事情到底了解多少？但我只是在想，纳粹宣传是在歌颂在波兰所做的事情，还是对此保持沉默。很显然，他们掩盖了他们所做的大量事情。我的意思是，他们不会说我们在轰炸医院、我们放火烧了学校、我们在村子里把人活活烧死。我的意思是，他们绝对不会这么做。所以是的，合理地说，你可以说他们对此一无所知。但即便如此，
you know, they're pummeling Warsaw into submission, people are gathering in shops to look at maps and they'll follow the course of their army in their little pins, watch them with the bins exactly. And Chira says, as long as the Germans are successful and do not have to pull in their belts too much, this will not be an unpopular war. So let's just end by talking about what this all meant for Poland, a huge subject so we can only scratch the surface. Poland at the end of this war, which basically the whole thing is done and dusted in one month and a half in total mopping up in the countryside. It's been completely ravaged
你知道的，他们正把华沙轰炸得被迫投降，人们聚集在商店里看地图，并用小图钉追踪他们军队的进程，精确地看着他们。夏伊勒说，只要德国人取得成功，又不需要勒紧太多裤腰带，这就不会是一场不受欢迎的战争。所以让我们以讨论这一切对波兰意味着什么来结尾吧，这是一个宏大的主题，我们只能略窥一二。在这场战争结束时，整场战争总共在一个半月内就彻底结束并完成了清扫工作，波兰已经被彻底满目疮痍
on a scale, I think unimaginable at any previous point in human history, because particularly of the air campaign. Probably 66,000 Polish soldiers were dead, civilian deaths, impossible to say, maybe 100,000, maybe 200,000, maybe fewer, it's hard to say. What happened to Poland, there was a lot of dithering about what the Nazis and the Russians would do, but in the end, Western Poland was annexed by the Reich. That's about 10 million people. Stalin took the Eastern bit, so that's about 13 million people, and that was given to the Republics of Belarus and Ukraine where it remains today. So we will hear next time, Thursday's episode, about what happens in in Stalin's bit of Poland, the killings of tens of thousands of professional people and officers and so on, the people put in prison camps,
在人类历史上的任何此前阶段，这都是难以想象的规模，尤其是因为空袭。大概有6,600名波兰士兵阵亡，平民死亡人数难以统计，也许10万，也许20万，也许更少，很难说。波兰的遭遇是，纳粹和俄国人会怎么做有过很多犹豫不决，但最后，波兰西部被帝国吞并。大约有1,000万人。斯大林占领了东部，大约有1,300万人，这部分被分给了白俄罗斯和乌克兰共和国，直到今天依然如此。所以我们将在下一次，也就是周四的节目中，听到在斯大林占领的波兰部分发生了什么，数以万计的专业人士和军官等被杀害，人们被关进监狱，
and in particular the one and a half million people who are put into cattle trucks and then are deported to Kazakhstan or to Siberia. And these are people, I mean, it's not just anybody who's a professional person who's in the army, who owns land or anything like that, but even Stalin deported people who, if you spoke Esperanto, if you collected stamps, if you had kind of cosmopolitan tendencies, a sense of sophistication and integration into European culture. You know, you are out, you're off. Yes. That left a kind of rump bit of Poland in sort of the south and the center around Warsaw and Krakow, which had about 11 million people.
尤其是那一百五十万人被塞进牛车，然后被流放到哈萨克斯坦或西伯利亚。这些人，我的意思是，不仅是任何在军队里的专业人士、拥有土地的人或类似的人，甚至斯大林还流放了那些——如果你说世界语，如果你收集邮票，如果你有某种大都市倾向、老练感以及对欧洲文化的融入。你知道，你出局了，你完了。是的。这在南部和中部围绕华沙和克拉科夫一带留下了波兰的一小块残余，大约有一千一百万人。
And there was some talk, well, we have a kind of rump state and they said basically, no, we'll just leave this as a kind of weird appendage, kind of semi-legal colony called the General Government. And it was ruled by Hans Frank, the Nazi lawyer. And this, the General Government, becomes the location for some of the worst atrocities of the Holocaust. So if the big camps, Treblinka, Majdanek, Sobibor, and Belzec are all in the General Government. Sobibor and Belzec are all in there, the general government. And in these areas, Polishness is, they attempt to eradicate Polishness itself. They shut down all the schools, the universities, the libraries, the museums. Polish music is banned, Chopin is banned.
当时有一些讨论，嗯，我们有一个类似残余的国家，他们基本上说，不，我们只会把它当作一个奇怪的附属物，一种被称为总督府的半合法殖民地。它由纳粹律师汉斯·弗兰克统治。这个总督府成为了大屠杀中一些最严重暴行的发生地。所以如果说特雷布林卡、迈达内克、索比堡和贝乌热茨这些大型集中营都在总督府。索比堡和贝乌热茨都在那里，即总督府。在这些地区，波兰性是——他们企图根除波兰性本身。他们关闭了所有的学校、大学、图书馆、博物馆。波兰音乐被禁，肖邦被禁。
They abolish Polish names, don't they? So the town of Oswiecien becomes Auschwitz. Auschwitz, exactly. National monuments are blown up, teachers are murdered, all of this kind of thing. In the first three months of the year, the SS and the German militias of various kinds probably murdered, I don't know, 65, 70,000 people, priests, intellectuals, professional people. But also it's not just working through their lists.
他们废除了波兰语的地名，对吧？所以奥斯威辛镇变成了奥斯威辛。奥斯威辛，确实如此。国家纪念碑被炸毁，教师被谋杀，诸如此类的事情。在这一年的前三个月，党卫军和各种德国民兵大概谋杀了我不知道，6.5万到7万名，神职人员、知识分子、专业人士。但同时，这不仅仅是按名单行事。
They're also killing people almost at random. So I'll give you a tiny example. It's just one small example that can stand for so many. There's a town called Gdynia in the north, uh, called Obwuzha. And there, one day somebody smashed a window at the German police station. And the SS knew it was someone from the school and they rounded up 50 boys in the school and said, who did it? And these boys, teenage boys, they refused to give up the
他们还在几乎随机杀人。所以我举个微不足道的例子。这只是一个可以代表许许多多同类事件的小例子。北部有一个叫格丁尼亚的镇，呃，叫奥布武扎。在那里，有一天有人砸碎了德国警察局的一扇窗户。党卫军知道那是学校里的某个人，于是他们在学校里搜捕了50名男孩，问是谁干的。这些男孩，十几岁的男孩，他们拒绝交出
culprit. And the SS called these boys parents and said we want you to beat up your own children, to beat them in front of the local church. And the parents said we're not going to beat our own children. So the SS said great well we'll do it then. So they beat these boys with their rifle butts and then shot and killed 10 of them. And they left their bodies lying in front of the church the whole of the next day as a lesson to the people of the village. And that story is just one among countless stories of the kind of random brutality that would become the norm in Nazi occupied Poland. Which is effectively as close to hell on earth.
罪魁祸首。党卫军把这些男孩的父母叫来，说我们希望你们痛殴你们自己的孩子，在当地教堂前痛殴他们。父母们说我们不会打自己的孩子。所以党卫军说，很好，那我们来。于是他们用步枪托殴打这些男孩，然后开枪打死了其中10个。他们把尸体扔在教堂前一整天，以此来给村里的人上一课。这个故事只是无数关于随机残暴行为的故事中的一个，而这种残暴行为后来成为了纳粹占领下波兰的常态。这实际上堪称人间地狱。
Yeah, as you get in. As you would get. In European history, I think it's fair to say. I mean, if there's one place you don't want to be in your all European history, is Poland between 1939 and 1945, especially if you're Jewish. Because with the division of Poland
是的，正如你所经历的。正如你所会经历的。在欧洲历史上，我认为这样说很公平。我的意思是，如果在你所有的欧洲历史中有一个你最不想去的地方，那就是1939年到1945年之间的波兰，特别是如果你是犹太人的话。因为随着波兰的瓜分
of those three and a half million Jews, two million of them immediately have fallen into the hands of the Nazis. Now, even before the fall of Warsaw, Hitler is thinking about what to do with this population. And he says, why don't we put everybody into the general government, into this kind of weird colony that we've got centered on Warsaw and Krakow. Even at this point, Heydrich from the SS is saying we'll corral these people in the general government, but this is just a step towards what Heydrich calls the final aim. And at this point it's not clear what that will be. Maybe putting these
在那三百五十万犹太人中，有两百万人直接落入了纳粹手中。现在，甚至在华沙陷落之前，希特勒就在考虑如何处理这部分人口。他说，为什么我们不把每个人都放进总督府，放进这个以华沙和克拉科夫为中心的奇怪殖民地里呢？甚至在这个时候，党卫军的海德里希也在说，我们会把这些人圈在总督府里，但这只是海德里希所称的最终目标的其中一步。而此时还不清楚那会是什么。也许把这些人
people in a reservation somewhere further east? Unclear. But even at this point, we'll just end with this, there are hints of a much darker outcome. That autumn, Goebbels went to visit a ghetto in Łódź, where a lot of Polish Jews lived, and he was shocked at what he saw. He said, these aren't human beings, these are animals. He said, so our task is not the humanitarian one, Goebbels said, it's a surgical task. We have to take steps and really radical steps because otherwise Europe will perish through the Jewish disease. And a month later, he had a chat with Hitler and Hitler said to him, you know, we're going to have to turn to this Jewish and Polish question very soon
放在更东边的某个保留地里？还不清楚。但即使在此时，我们就以此结束，有迹象表明会有更黑暗的结果。那年秋天，戈培尔去参观了罗兹的一个犹太隔离区，那里居住着许多波兰犹太人，他被眼前的景象震惊了。他说，这些不是人，这些是动物。他说，所以我们的任务不是人道主义任务，戈培尔说，这是一项外科手术式的任务。我们必须采取措施，而且是非常激进的措施，否则欧洲将因犹太人的疾病而灭亡。一个月后，他与希特勒进行了交谈，希特勒对他说，你知道的，我们很快就得转向解决这个犹太和波兰问题
because he said, if we're not careful in a few generations, it will reappear to kind of haunt us. So we have to be clear about this. There is no panacea. We have to take radical measures. And I quote, the Jewish danger must be banished from us. And Tom, I think everybody listening to this will know where that particular story is heading. Absolutely. Dominic, thanks. I mean, that was a brutal, harrowing, terrifying episode. And that ends our account of the Nazi invasion of Poland. But we are not gonna leave this story completely.
因为他说，如果我们不小心，在几代人的时间里，它会再次出现来困扰我们。所以我们必须对此有清醒的认识。没有什么灵丹妙药。我们必须采取激进的措施。我引述一下，必须把犹太人的危险从我们中间驱逐出去。汤姆，我想听这个节目的每个人都会知道那个特定故事的走向。当然。多米尼克，谢谢。我的意思是，那是一场残酷、悲惨、可怕的剧集。我们的纳粹入侵波兰纪实到此结束。但我们不会完全抛开这个故事。
We have an episode that is a kind of coda to the conquest of Poland, but is also a kind of palette cleanser. It's a story that takes us into the kind of the dark heart of Poland's fate in the Second World War. But I think it also offers perhaps perhaps a sense of hope and redemption, because amazingly it features at its heart, the story of a bear. And we will be back with that on Thursday. The story of Wojtek, a bear that is very well known in Poland, Dominik, and should, I think, be better known here. So you can hear that episode on Thursday. But for now, goodbye. Goodbye.
我们有一集，它有点像是征服波兰的尾声，但同时也是一种清口剂。这是一个将我们带入第二次世界大战中波兰命运黑暗核心的故事。但我也认为它或许带来了一种希望和救赎感，因为令人惊异的是，它的核心是一个关于熊的故事。我们将在周四的节目中回归这个故事。关于沃伊泰克的发人深省的故事，这只熊在波兰非常有名，多米尼克，而且我认为在这里也应该更有名。所以你可以在周四收听那一集。但现在，再见。再见。
Here is that clip from our mini- on Trump's insurrection. And these senators are being kind of ushered out through a very narrow corridor. And one of them says we were 20 feet away from the rioters. If the rioters had just looked the other way and seen that a whole bunch of senators were coming out, who knows what would have happened? Who knows what could have happened to Mike Pence? And I think it is important to point out that Donald Trump was getting these reports and did not care.
这里是我们关于特朗普暴动的小专题中的那段音频。这些参议员正被引导着穿过一条非常狭窄的走廊。其中一个人说，我们距离暴徒只有20英尺远。如果暴徒只是朝另一个方向看一眼，看到一大群参议员正走出来，谁知道会发生什么？谁知道迈克·彭斯会发生什么？我认为指出这一点很重要，那就是唐纳德·特朗普当时正在接收这些报告却根本不在乎。
The Senate has been evacuated at 2.18 PM. Nancy Pelosi is also pulled out of her chair by the Capitol police and taken off the podium and taken to a safe location at Fort McNair in Southwest Washington. She originally tried to stay. She didn't want to leave the building, but because of security, she had to get out of there. One of the Democratic members of the Congress at this point, as they realized that the rioters are starting to breach their area, one of the Democratic members of Congress yells down to the Republicans, this is because of you. And the members are getting texts. This is how they know that things
参议院已于下午2点18分疏散。南希·佩洛西也被国会警察从她的椅子上拉开，带离主席台，并带到了位于华盛顿西南麦克奈尔堡的安全地点。她最初试图留下来。她不想离开大楼，但出于安全考虑，她必须离开那里。此时，国会的一位民主党议员意识到暴徒开始突破他们的区域时，这位民主党国会成员向共和党人喊道，这是因为你们。议员们正在收到短信。这就是他们如何得知事情
are bad because they're getting texts from their family saying, what are you doing there? Why haven't you left? Are you safe? But they haven't got a television. They're not watching it. They're trying to get on with the business of the day. I mean, it's this surreal. I keep thinking how surreal it was that inside the chambers, they're trying to do business as usual and feet away. The rioters are there saying that they want to have some of these people hung and that they want to overturn the election result. So then a few minutes after that, the house floor is evacuated, literally in front of the rioters. The police manage again to secure a very narrow passageway through the rioters to get them out. And one member afterwards says, I could look in the eyes of those officers and I saw the fear.
很糟糕，因为他们收到家人的短信说，你在那里干什么？你为什么还没走？你安全吗？但他们没有电视。他们没有在看。他们正试图继续处理当天的事务。我的意思是，这太超现实了。我一直在想，议会大厅里面的人试图一切照旧，而几英尺外，暴徒们却在那里说他们想把这些人中的一些人绞死，他们想推翻选举结果，这有多么超现实。就在几分钟后，众议院大厅被疏散，简直就在暴徒面前。警察再次设法在暴徒中开辟了一条非常狭窄的通道让他们撤离。事后有一位议员说，我能看着那些警官的眼睛，我看到了恐惧。
They knew that the officers were outnumbered. To hear more, search the Rest is politics, U.S. wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他们知道警官们寡不敌众。要了解更多信息，请在您获取播客的任何地方搜索“The Rest is Politics U.S.”。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。